Exzellent
Windhaus
Windhaus logisch
Echt der Wahnsinn, was haben wir jetzt für eine Musik an? Keine Ahnung, machen wir irgendwas anderes an
Oh, das China-Restaurant
So, also, weiter gehts. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben, nachdem da scheiß nicht funktioniert? Jetzt klappt es übrigens wieder
Jetzt hat sich, jetzt hat sich eingekriegt Windhaus. Ich weiß nicht, was das für Probleme hatte. Ich hoffe, das hat sich jetzt erledigt
Aber das sind so typische Windhaus-Geschichten, wo du dich immer fragst, warum macht der sowas zwischendurch?
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Genau, also das werde ich mal im nächsten Stream mit der Kamera probieren, dass man eben sieht, was ich bastle
Und ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Ich habe hier dieses Video gefunden, 5 Hardware-Mythen, die einfach gelogen sind
Hat mich ein bisschen an meine Serie erinnert, die ich mal bei mir gemacht habe auf dem Channel
Mal angucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, was er erzählt
Schlechte Treiber, für was? Das hat noch nicht mal Treiber, das ist irgendwie, irgendeine Windhaus-Service-Maus-Sharing-Geschichte
Die auch bisher immer funktioniert hat, keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hatte
Ich weiß nicht, man weiß nicht genau, was der für Schmerzen hatte
Zumindest, so eine Stream ist wieder da
Mal erst mal refreshen, ja, das hier die Sachen laden
Jetzt mal kurz gucken, Lautstärke stimmt, Windhaus stellt ja auch ganz gern was um
Sound, Recording, Levels, korrekt, korrekt, alles gut, Teams war nicht am Start
So, ok, jetzt können wir ja loslegen
Jetzt können wir ja loslegen, nachdem das jetzt so lange gedauert hat mit der Maus
So, jetzt bin ich voll rausgekommen, weil ich neu starten muss zwischendurch
Dummer Mythos von Konsolenspielern, man muss seinen PC ständig aufrüsten, ne, das stimmt ja wieder nicht mehr
Mittlerweile ist es ja komplett un-anders, mittlerweile musst du öfters eine neue Konsole kaufen als einen neuen PC
Überlegt euch mal, ich hab vor drei Jahren meinen PC gekauft, immer noch oberes, oberes Ende, das ist der absolute Witz
In der Zeit konntest du dir ja schon wieder drei neue Playstations kaufen, ja fast
Fast, nicht ganz
Dann gehts sogar mehr als Administrator, ok, aber warum ist das überhaupt so scheiße gemacht wieder, ey Windhaus, was soll das
Unser Linux war ich sudo, such mir mit PS irgendwie das Ding raus, kill und wenns gar nicht geht, kill minus 9, dann ist auf jeden Fall blatt
Und wenn das mit kill minus 9 nicht kaputt geht, dann ist irgendwas ganz im Arsch
Warum benutzt du CMDA statt Windhaus Terminal, weil es CMDA schon länger gibt und ich das einfach schon die ganze Zeit verwendet hab, bevor es das Windhaus Terminal gegeben hat
Und das Windhaus Terminal, ich weiß es leider aus dem Kopf nicht mehr genau, was das für Schmerzen hatte, es hatte, wir hatten es uns im Stream angeguckt
Das hatte irgendwas, was mich genervt hat
Irgendwas, was war das denn, dass der Escape-Sync-Sequenzen im Wirm nicht richtig erkannt hat
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, irgendwas ging mir am Windhaus Terminal voll auf den Keks, es kann aber sein, dass das mittlerweile gefixt ist
Dein PC hat aber auch den Preis von drei Konsolen, die hätte es mir egal, Preis interessiert mich ja nicht
Danke YouTube-Money, geh einfach darum, dass in der Zeit, also in der Zeit, wo du dir aktuell einen High-End-Rechner gekauft hast, hättest du dir eine Playstation 4 kaufen müssen und eine Playstation 4 Pro kaufen müssen, wenn du aktuell bleiben willst
Wobei die Playstation 4, die kam ja auch 2013, das ist auch schon wieder 7 Jahre her, ja doch, passt doch, kommt doch hin
So, also gucken wir uns mal das Video an, also was erzählt er uns hier, 5 Hard-Filme, die einfach gelungen sind, also ich predikte da jetzt einfach mal was
Und zwar, kurz hier aus, komm mal hier, Michael 50 Billionen hat, macht Chill-Stab, wusste ich auch noch nicht
Ich predikte mal, was er da so für Mythen drin hat, das sind wahrscheinlich, weil das, ich kenn das noch von meiner eigenen Serie, die ich dazu gemacht hab, man fängt an mit den absolut banalsten Dingern
So, nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, mehr CPU-Kerne machen die Sachen nicht unbedingt schneller, oder zwei Grafikkarten sind besser als eine, oder mehr RAM macht dein System schneller, oder was auch immer
So Dinge, man fängt meistens mit Easy-Sachen an und ich glaube, das ist ja auch so
Gut, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, was er erzählt
Also im PC- und Hardware-Bereich, da sagt der eine das, der andere dies und wenn man sich noch nicht so richtig auskennt, weiß man am Ende auch nicht
Also im Hardware-Bereich sagt vor allem jeder, dass er sich wahnsinnig gut auskennt, obwohl er sich nicht auskennt
Das ist eigentlich so, generell das Internet, vor allem Reddit, da ist das ja ganz schlimm
Wenn du auf irgendeinen Subreddit gehst, von, es ist egal zu was, zu irgendeinem, was man streamt, ist leise, ne da ist nix leise
Das ist so laut wie immer, das ist überhaupt kein Unterschied zu sonst
Vielleicht hast du die Browser irgendwie rumgestellt, also gerade auf Reddit ist es so, egal ob du jetzt auf den Subreddit von einem Spiel gehst, pass auf exile
Oder ob du jetzt auf den Hardware-Subreddit gehst, ey, wenn du von dem Thema keine Ahnung hast, du weißt gar nicht, wem du glauben sollst
Zum Beispiel, wenn es um das Thema NAS, Storage und sonst was geht, da hast du Leute, die schwören, wie sagt man das, Stein und Bein, was auch immer
Die schwören auf ihre Mutter quasi, dass du um einen ZFS NAS oder ZFS Storage zu betreiben, dass du mindestens ECC RAM brauchst und mindestens einen Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte speichern
Was unter dem Strich, kompletter Schwachsinn ist, wenn man das vielleicht unter Enterprise Workload mit mehreren Usern oder sonst was betreiben will, sind das vielleicht ganz gute Richtwerte
Aber für eine NAS daheim, mit 1, 2 Usern, da brauch ich weder ECC RAM, das macht es ja nicht unsicherer, nur weil ich keinen ECC RAM hab, das macht es aber auch nicht besser im Vergleich zu einem normalen Fallensystem
Ich brauch keine, was weiß ich, 64G RAM, ich brauch keinen SSD Cache oder sonst was, das ist kompletter Blutsinn, ich kann für eine NAS daheim einfach 2 Platten nehmen, ZFS Rate 1 draufschmeißen und mich freuen und alles ist gut
Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, aber du hast Leute auf Reddit, die schwören wirklich auf ihre Mutter, das muss so sein, du kannst das nicht betreiben ohne ECC RAM, du kannst das nicht betreiben ohne 64G RAM, totaler Blutsinn
Und sowas hast du bei allen Sachen, so hast du zum Beispiel im Passive Exile Subreddit, hast du Leute, die sagen, das ist kein richtiges Build, wenn es mehr als 5 Chaos Orbs kostet oder mehr als 1 Exile kostet, das ist kein richtiges Build
Was natürlich kompletter Schwachsinn ist, weil die ganzen richtig guten Builds, die auch alles Content komplett zerstören, sind eben ein bisschen teurer, vor allem in der höheren Ausbaustufe
Also kompletter Bullshit und das ist so typisch Reddit, dass da jeder meint, er hat voll den Plan und wenn man selbst keine Ahnung hat, ist es ziemlich schwierig zu unterscheiden zwischen den Leuten, die wirklich sinnvolle Sachen schreiben und zwischen den Leuten, die einfach nur blödsinn auf Reddit schreiben
Deswegen ist eine Sache, woran man meiner Meinung nach gut erkennen kann, dass man sich mit einem Thema mittlerweile ganz gut auskennt, wenn man auf das jeweilige Reddit geht und halbwegs klassifizieren kann, wer von den Typen schreibt Stuss und wer schreibt was sinnvolles
Dann merkt man langsam, man kennt sich mit der Materie aus
Was ich auch auf Reddit rant, aber ihr wisst ja, ich werde manchmal ein bisschen sidetracked, zumindest was mir auch bei, was mir in Foren, und Reddit ist ja irgendwo ein Forum, auch extrem auf dem Keks geht, zum Beispiel das Arduino Forum in diesem Microcontroller Forum oder eben auch auf Reddit, wenn es um irgendwelche Hardware-Programmierungen oder sonst was geht, da hast du
Jemand, der fragt was ganz Simples, der fragt was ganz Simples, zum Beispiel, oder machen wir mal was nicht ganz so abstraktes, sagen wir jemand, jemand ist in einem Heimautomatisierungsforum und fragt, hey, wie kann ich mal, wie kann ich überprüfen, ob ich vergessen habe, das die Garage zuzumachen
Geht es dir finanziell eigentlich gut, ja alles in Ordnung, alles in Ordnung, wenn du willst, dass es mir besser geht, kannst du mir natürlich dein Prime-Sub dalassen, ich freue mich über jeden Sub, aber ich werde auch sonst nicht verhungern, ja
So und, also im Angenommen fragt jemand in irgendeinem Forum oder auf einem Heimautomatisierungsreddit, wie kann ich denn am einfachsten feststellen, ob ich vergessen habe, mein Garagentor auf oder zuzumachen, so, ganz einfache Frage, man könnte ihm eine ganz einfache Antwort geben, so nach dem Motto hier, schau dir mal
Beispiel 2, schau dir mal an, guck dir, du brauchst irgendwie eine Hardware, hol dir einen Raspberry Pi, installier Home Assistant und hol dir einen Wireless oder Wired, je nachdem, ob du Strom in deiner Garage hast, Sensor, der einfach checkt, ob das Tor auf und zu geht, entweder, wenn du es advanced machen willst, mit Neigung, dass du sogar weißt, wie viel das Garagentor offen ist oder einfach nur einen Open-Close-Sensor, dass du weißt, ob offen oder zu ist, so, ganz einfache Antwort und diese Antwort, die geben Leute, die ein bisschen Plan haben, die wissen, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was
sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie tun, was sie
immer aufreden, ja hast du dir schon mal Gedanken gemacht an einen Kubernetes-Cluster aufzusetzen, weil wenn du mit Container-Orchestrierung am Start bist, dann ist es ja total einfach zu checken, ob dein
Garagentor offen ist oder zu ist und dann, und dann, was diese Shit-Poster immer noch dabei schreiben,
was diese Shit-Poster immer noch dabei schreiben ist, also bei mir ist das aktuell so, ich habe drei
drei Cluster verteilt in ganz Deutschland mit Rancher-OS, die sich über Kubernetes, das ergibt keinen Sinn, ich weiß ja,
mit einer Ahnung von euch, es stimmt nicht, was ich erzähle, ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn,
geclustert sind hier mit Heartbeat-Technologie über ganz Deutschland verteilt, wo dann mein Garagentor-Sensor drüber
Load-Balanced wird, so ist das bei mir und so richtig geil und der Typ, der neu ist und einfach nur wissen will, ob sein
Garagentor auf und zu ist, der sitzt dann da und denkt, alter was will der Dude eigentlich von mir, ich will doch einfach nur gucken, ob mein
Garagentor auf und zu ist.
Das hat es übrigens aus technischer Sicht absolut keinen Sinn ergeben, was ich gerade erzählt habe, aber so sind die Antworten oder auch
oder auch, wenn irgendeiner, ich weiß, wir sind sieben Sekunden in dem Video und ich bin schon side-tracked ohne Ende,
aber auch, wenn man beispielsweise mal in irgendeinen Microcontroller-Forum guckt, Arduino-Forum, ESP-Reddit oder sonst was, da hast du Leute, die
Fragen was ganz einfaches, so nach dem Motto, okay,
ich habe einen Button, ich will auf den Button drücken und das will ich in meinem Programm-Code mitbekommen, also eigentlich eines der simpelsten Sachen
schlechthin, anstatt, dass ihm entweder einer eine
drei Zeilen Demo schreibt, wie das funktioniert, oder den Link postet auf den GitHub-Example, wo das drinne steht,
kommen die Leute da an, ja, hast du dir auch schon mal Gedanken gemacht, dass der Button richtig debaunst ist?
Ja, und wenn du das so programmierst, dann ist das natürlich totaler Mist, du musst das so programmieren, danach musst du noch Hardware-Interrupts verwenden,
natürlich den ESP32-Hardware-Timer, dass du gucken kannst, ob das ganze richtig resettet wird,
die meisten Antworten kriege ich absolute Anfälle, wenn ich die auf Reddit lese.
So, und deswegen bin ich der Ansicht, man kann halbwegs erkennen, ob man sich langsam in irgendeinem Thema ganz
passabel auskennt, wenn man die
Antworten auf Reddit klassifizieren kann,
zwischen
der Typ weiß, was er schreibt, und der Typ schreibt Mist, dann wenn man damit anfängt,
weiß man, man kennt sich ganz gut aus, herz390 geht da drum, wie die Leute, dass die meisten Leute in Foren oder auf Reddit blöd sind schreiben.
Nein, ich kenne keinen Laura-Sensor, der ein Türschloss überwacht, aber was du machen kannst, ist,
du kannst gucken, ob die Tür auf und zu ist, und das machst du zwar nicht mit Laura, sondern du machst, nimmst
ein Low-Power-Board mit Laura, machst dort den Sensor dran,
und der Sensor triggert, also wacht das Ding aus dem Deep Sleep aus, und lässt es dann über Laura schicken, aber das ist nicht so schön, das ist nicht so schön, weil das ist nicht so klein.
Ja, so selbst so ein ESP32-Board mit Laura, sonst was drauf, erstens muss man das selbst programmieren,
und zweitens ist das ja auch schon so 4 cm groß, also ein ganz kleines Sensor mit Laura, der für sowas ist, kenne ich nicht, es gibt eh wenige Standalone-Laura-Sensoren, die erschwinglich sind, so egal, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video an, schauen wir uns an, also was er, was er hat, wie gesagt, ich predicte, dass da so Sachen kommen, wie mehr CPUs, nicht automatisch schneller und solche, solche Geschichten,
ähm, so, ich muss mal kurz was gucken, wenn man an JSON-File startet, ja Windows-Logik, das geht mir auch teilweise auf den Keks, wenn was Windows für Default-Programme startet,
achso, stimmt, irgendjemand hat gefragt, warum ich keine Axis-Kameras nehme, da habe ich gesagt, weil die Dinger zu übelst teuer sind,
Da wollte ich hier nämlich gucken, weil, wenn man sich hier anguckt, was sein Kram kostet.
Alter, das sieht das mit Dark Realer Kacke aus.
Die Dinger sind, die Dinger sind viel zu, viel zu, wenn man sich die Networkkameras guckt.
Die Dinger, die sind vielleicht ganz gut, aber preisleistungsmäßig finde ich die übelst, übelst teuer.
Nehmen wir jetzt zum Beispiel mal irgend so ein, warte mal, Explosion Protected Cameras, ja genau.
Hier, sowas.
Und jetzt suchen wir einfach mal danach jetzt.
Das kostet wahrscheinlich 500 Euro oder so.
Ah, easy, 300 Euro.
300 Euro, das mag zwar nicht schlecht sein, aber ich kriege für 80 Euro eine China Cam,
die mehr oder weniger das gleiche macht, nämlich einfach ein Bild von meinem Hoftor übertragen.
Dass die andere noch mehr Features hat und wahrscheinlich einfacher einzurichten, ist besser zu funktionieren.
Wage ich gar nicht hier irgendwie infrage zu stellen, ist wahrscheinlich so.
Hast du schon gesagt, welche Cams du nimmst?
Ja, ich habe jetzt die gestern verbaut.
Nicht die hier, die habe ich nämlich noch übrig, die will ich für den Stream verwenden.
RLC, die hier habe ich gestern verbaut.
Mit meinem Akkuschrauber habe ich Löcher gebohrt, in die Wand und Dübel reingemacht.
Ich war erst skeptisch, ob das mit dem Akkuschrauber funktioniert, aber ganz ehrlich, warum nicht?
Weil ich habe keinen Bohrer, also ich habe keine richtige Bohrmaschine.
Aber es geht ohne Probleme mit dem 12-Volt-Akkuschrauber, gar kein Ding.
Das ging easy as fuck einfach schüpp, also ohne jeglichen Widerstand in die Wand rein.
Licky Brain, drei Monate, dankeschön, exellent.
Genau, an die Wand geschraubt, Hoftor, ich gucke mal, ob ich euch das zeigen kann.
Moment, ich muss mal gucken, dass man gerade nichts sieht, dass hier gerade nichts geleakt wird wieder.
Na, das wollen wir ja nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, da kommt gerade ein Zug, den sieht man, das kann ich euch nicht zeigen.
Das kann ich euch gerade nicht zeigen, weil da steigen gerade Leute aus dem Zug aus.
Ich sehe das oben links in der Kamera, das kann ich euch gerade nicht zeigen.
Ja, überhaupt kein Ding hier.
Ich habe mir den 12-Volt-GSR, ich habe das ohne Schlagbohrfunktion.
Ich glaube, dass da habe ich dieses Set, dieses Set habe ich, da hast du Bohrer dabei für Stein, Holz und ein paar Bits, ein Zusatzakku und sonst was.
Und das Ding, also wie gesagt, ich habe ohne Schlagfunktion.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der GSB oder der GSR ist und das ging total einfach in die Wand rein.
Easy, einfach hier diesen Bohrer genommen, also die rechten sind Holz, die linken sind für Stein.
Einfach den 5er Bohrer genommen, das Ding hier auf den zweiten Gang gestellt und ging easy in die Wand rein, überhaupt kein Problem.
Also ich denke mal, wenn man jetzt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes macht, als Löcher zu bohren, dann ist es vielleicht besser.
Man kauft sich eine richtige Bohrmaschine, aber für ab und zu mal 3 Löcher in die Wand bohren geht das schon.
So, mal gucken, ob die Bahn jetzt weg ist, ob ich euch jetzt zeigen kann, wie die Kamera aussieht.
Hier ganz schnell, ganz schnell, no leak, no leak.
Ja, so, hier, guck da, Hof.
Funktioniert alles, alles hier mit der Chinacam.
Waren die linken Bohrer nicht für Eisen? Keine Ahnung, die rechten sind auf jeden Fall für Holz.
Die rechten sind auf jeden Fall für Holz, deswegen musste ich die linken nehmen.
So, ok, jetzt gucken wir uns auch mal das Video an, wieder mal langsam Zeit.
Leak, MockerS, ich hab meinen Hoftor zum 20. Mal geleakt, ja.
So, mein Hoftor darf ich aufnehmen.
Mein Hoftor darf ich aufnehmen. Ich mein, ich mach ja keine Motionerkennung oder sonst was.
Ich nehm das auch nicht, ich nehm das auch nicht auf.
Ich mach das ja nur als Livestream.
Und ich mein, wenn die Kamera so ein großes Sichtfeld hat, und ich mein, ihr habt's ja gesehen,
da ist ja sogar noch so Wellplastik davor.
Also man sieht nichts, man sieht höchstens in, keine Ahnung, 100 Meter Entfernung den Zug.
Aber das erkennst du nicht mal, die Leute, also das ist glaube ich kein Problem.
Ansonsten erkennst du nichts.
So, auf geht's.
Mehr, was man glauben soll.
In diesem Video decken wir mal fünf Hardware-Mythen auf, die zwar immer so behauptet werden,
schlichtweg allerdings einfach nicht stimmen. Viel Spaß.
Ja, bin ich mal gespannt jetzt.
Online-Banking ist mittlerweile unerlässlich und gerade...
Was hältst du vor Metabo, Akkuschrauber?
Ich hatte kein Metabo, ich hatte weder Makita noch Metabo noch D-Wort noch Milwaukee noch sonst was.
Ich hatte bisher nur diesen 12V Bosch Akkuschrauber, dem bin ich zufrieden.
Smartphone ist das Bezahlen online super angenehm.
Moment, ist das Sellout?
Fängt der wirklich sein Video mit Sellout an?
So, decken wir mal fünf Hardware-Mythen auf, die zwar immer so behauptet werden,
schlichtweg allerdings einfach nicht stimmen. Viel Spaß.
Moment.
Online-Banking ist mittlerweile unerlässlich und gerade am Smartphone ist das Bezahlen online super angenehm.
Einige Vorteile bietet da...
Einfach direkt mit Sellout anfangen.
Das habe ich mich nicht getraut auf YouTube immer.
Ich wollte zu mit, weil da springen die Leute immer reihenweise ab, aber anscheinend scheint das bei ihm zu funktionieren.
Geil.
Braucht ihr also jetzt noch ein...
Halbwissen ist gefährlich.
Okay, wo geht's denn los?
Einen Link findet ihr unten in der Infobox.
Aber krass, eine Minute Sellout am Anfang.
Halbwissen ist gefährlich.
Moin Michael, 5...
...trillionen.
C und Hardware-Bereich trifft das vielleicht nicht speziell zu.
Fakt ist allerdings, dass viel Halbwissen im Netz kursiert und mit fünf dieser Mythen räumen wir jetzt mal auf.
Wenn euch diese Reihe gefällt, dann lasst jetzt auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Daumen in nördlicher Richtung da,
denn dann machen wir das hier vielleicht auch mal häufiger.
Nördlicher Richtung ist nördlich, nicht unten.
Mythos Nummer eins.
Mehr RAM macht den PC schneller.
Und das stimmt natürlich nur bedingt, denn...
Okay, okay.
Wir machen das jetzt mal so.
Ich gebe mal kurz meinen Senf dazu und dann gucken wir uns an, was er dazu sagt.
Mehr RAM macht den PC schneller.
Das ist natürlich blöd, denn das RAM an sich den PC schneller macht.
Das einzige Sache ist, wenn man zu wenig RAM hat und das Ding wie verrückt rumswappt.
Dann bringt mehr RAM was.
Wenn man genug RAM hat, wenn ich nicht irgendwie an irgendeine Grenze stoße, wenn ich 16G hab,
und ich komm damit aus, ob ich jetzt 32G reinmache, ist vollkommen egal.
Mehr RAM macht den PC schneller.
Und das stimmt natürlich nur bedingt, denn der PC wird nur schneller, wenn der RAM RGB beleuchtet ist.
Richtig, richtig, richtig.
Endlich sagt's mal einer.
Richtig, so ist es.
Aber jetzt mal Spaß beiseite.
Was heißt hier Spaß?
Ich geh zum FPS, das ist kein Spaß.
Wir machen einfach mal, ihr habt 8 oder 16GB RAM.
Lohnt sich mehr als 16GB für Spiele.
Da brauchste, da musste schon mehrere Sachen parallel laufen.
Aber mir fallen keine Spiele ein, die wirklich 16G RAM brauchen.
Warum ich 32G RAM drinne hab, ist erstens, weil es billig ist aktuell.
Ich hab mir das erst gekauft vor 3 Monaten oder so, oder 4 Monaten, die 2. 16G.
Und weil ich viele VMs hab.
Ist das Werbung für Vengeance pro RAM?
Ach, das ist Schwachsinn.
Das ist auch Blödsinn.
Also ganz ehrlich, ja, theoretisch ist schnellerer RAM schneller, weil er ist halt schneller.
Aber das ist im einstelligen Prozentbereich.
Wenn es über die Messungenauigkeit rausgeht.
Die coolen Leute sagen auch RAM.
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Warte mal, warte mal, der nächste Punkt, warte mal.
Hat das jemand schon...
Also, das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ehrlich, das hab ich noch nie gehört.
China-Netzteile zerstören den PC.
Zu stark wäre er nicht.
Das ist doch Schwachsinn.
Also das kann ja nur wirklich ein absoluter Low-Brain-Noob erzählen.
Und das ist schon mal unlogisch aufgrund einer sehr einfachen Erklärung.
Na gut, diese Sache mit 80 Plus, das gilt ja, glaube ich, auch nur, ich glaube, ab 30 oder 40, oder, nee, 20%, 20, 30%, also sprich, diese 80-Plus-Zertifizierung heißt ja nur, dass ab, ich glaube, 30%-Auslastung, 20, 50, 80, genau, Chad.
Dass ab 20% die Dinger den gewissen Mindestwert erreichen.
Wenn man jetzt da irgendwie einen 1500 Watt-Ding rein klatscht und man idelt irgendwie mit 15 Watt-Idel rum, dann muss das nicht sonderlich effektiv sein.
Weil die Sache halt die ist, dann brauchst du auch nicht so viel. Aber es macht schon ein bisschen was aus.
Also ich würde immer gucken, dass ich ein größeres Netzteil brauche als das, was ich da maximal mal irgendwie messe.
Also sprich, man misst ja nicht die Teile innen drin, man misst ja da irgendwie mit einem Zwischenstecker. Also weil die Sache ist halt die, du kannst schon die ein oder anderen Peaks mal haben.
Sei es beim Einschalten, beim Anlaufen von irgendwelchen Festplatten, irgendwelche Grafikkarten-Geschichten.
Aber wenn du ein 500 Watt Netzteil hast, da bist du, oder 600 Watt ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, da bist du komplett auf der sicheren Seite bei aktuellen Rechnern.
Das Zeug ist mittlerweile, da sind ja keine Pentium 4s mehr, die extra Gehäuse brauchen, dass du sie gekühlt kriegst.
Wenn du ein PC kaufst, vielleicht einfach mal auf ein leicht stärkeres Netzteil setzen.
Außerdem kannst du relativ einfach bei der Grafikkarte gucken, bei der CPU gucken, was die maximal brauchen können.
Und da über 500 zu kommen, da musst du schon superfette CPU übertaktet haben, High-End-Grafikkarte am besten auch noch, die das Power-Limit draufgesetzt haben.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen RGB-Beleuchtung und sonst was, dann kommst du über 500, 600. Aber das reicht normalerweise ohne Probleme aus.
Mythos Nummer 3, AMD. Das hatte ich auch. Das hatte ich auch schon. Das hatte ich bei mir in dieser Mythos, in dieser IT-Mythen-Serie auch, was natürlich kompletter Blödsinn ist.
Grafikkarten laufen besser mit AMD als Intel-CPUs. Ja, auch im PC- und Hardware-Bereich gibt es Fanboys und verschiedene Lager.
Da wäre das grüne Lager mit Nvidia, das blaue Lager mit Intel und das rote Lager mit AMD.
Und oh mein Gott, der Mythos, dass AMD-Grafikkarten besser mit AMD-CPUs harmonieren, ist der größte Blödsinn.
Ja, das ist wirklich Schwachsinn.
Denn am Ende ist es so, dass ihr eine Grafikkarte mit PCI-Express 3.0 oder auch eine neuere mit PCI-Express 4.0 habt und die braucht eben nun mal einen PCI-Express-Slot von eurem Mainboard.
Kann euer Mutterbrett diesen bereitstellen und ihr habt nicht ein uraltes AGP-Mainboard, dann spielt es verdammt nochmal keine Rolle,
ob ihr eine Ryzen-CPU oder meinetwegen auch einen Intel Core To Do besitzt.
Die Grafikkarte versteht sich mit der Intel-CPU genauso gut wie mit der AMD-CPU. Wichtig ist nur eine Sache.
Solange eure CPU die Grafikkarte nicht bottleneckt, ist es völlig egal, was ihr für einen Prozessor mit eurer AMD-Grafikkarte nutzt.
Aber woher kommt eigentlich dieser Mythos?
Das liegt so ein bisschen an den Spielepublishern, denn alle möglichen Spiele haben je nach Zusammenarbeit mit Hardware-Herstellern eine leicht bessere Performance mit AMD, Intel oder Nvidia.
Diese drei großen Hersteller investieren nämlich viel Geld in...
Ja, das sind die ganzen Games, die am Anfang irgendwie Nvidia einplanten oder AMD einplanten oder irgendwie Intel tippen.
Das ist aber kompletter Blödsinn, weil man muss sich mal überlegen, dass die Schnittstellen, wie das Ganze angesprochen wird, überhaupt keinen Unterschied macht.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, und da ist ein bisschen was dran, aber da denken die Leute nicht dran, die sowas behaupten, es gibt natürlich herstellerspezifische Sachen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt ein Spiel habe, was Nvidia Hairworks oder CUDA GPU-Berechnungssachen und Kram verwendet, dann würde das schon in Kombination mit der jeweiligen Hardware, die das kann, besser funktionieren oder halt eben überhaupt erst funktionieren,
sei denn es gibt den Software Fallback, wenn man die hat, das ist ja irgendwo logisch.
Genau, sowas wie Mantle, wobei Mantle ist ja immer noch da.
Heißt nicht mehr Mantle, sondern heißt jetzt Vulcan. Vulcan ist ja quasi Mantle, die etwas neuere Variante von Mantle.
Das wissen auch viele Leute nicht. AMD hat mit Mantle angefangen, hat festgestellt, der Kram hat sich überhaupt nicht durchgesetzt.
Und dann sind sie zu den OpenGL Leuten gegangen. Also wie genau das jetzt in welchem Ablauf gewesen ist, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Und die OpenGL Group, diese Chronos Group, die jetzt Vulcan macht, das ist quasi entstanden aus AMD Mantle.
Und Vulcan ist ja quasi das etwas neuere OpenGL, was mit OpenGL nicht so viel zu tun hat.
Es ist ein Prinzip plus das gleiche Gremium, was sich darum kümmert.
Und Vulcan ist ja schon bei vielen Sachen drinne.
Ich glaube Battlefield hat mittlerweile Vulcan Renderer.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall schwer im Kommen aktuell.
Hat den riesen Vorteil, das ist genau das neue Doom, hat den riesen Vorteil, es ist halt kein proprietärer DirectX Geschiss.
Und dadurch laufen Spiele potenziell auch unter anderen Plattformen besser.
Weil alles was DirectX verwendet, funktioniert halt standardmäßig nur unter Windows.
Oder halt mit abgedrehten Emulationstricks, wie beispielsweise diese DirectX zu Vulcan Schnittstelle, die es in Steam gibt jetzt.
Aber natürlich ist immer besser, wenn die Spiele direkt das verwenden, was dann auch auf der jeweiligen Plattform läuft.
Genau, DX, VK.
Und warum ihr im Intro eines Spiels dann immer Werbung für bestimmte Hardware-Hersteller seht.
Und dann wird das Spiel natürlich auch etwas besser auf der entsprechenden Hardware laufen.
Far Cry 5 beispielsweise performt etwas besser mit AMD.
CSGO wiederum performt meiner Erfahrung...
Bei CSGO ist es vollkommen wurscht, wie CSGO performt.
CSGO läuft überall mit maximal FPS.
Wahrung nach etwas besser auf Intel-CPUs.
Mythos Nummer 4.
Ein Bottleneck sollte man vermeiden.
Was?
Was ist denn damit jetzt gemeint?
Ich bin gerade verwirrt.
Ein Bottleneck sollte man vermeiden.
Also zum Beispiel, dass ich eine viel zu starke CPU kaufe und eine zu schwache Grafikkarte.
Oder eine mega starke Grafikkarte und schwache CPU.
Ja, sag mal so.
Es ist halt Geldverschwendung.
Das macht das System nicht wirklich schlechter.
Aber es ist halt Geldverschwendung.
Ein Bottleneck sollte man vermeiden.
Was genau ist eigentlich ein Bottleneck?
Ich habe den Begriff ja eben schon mal erwähnt.
Und auf Deutsch übersetzt bedeutet das ja Flaschenhals.
Und beschreibt im PC-Bereich das...
Ein Bottleneck heißt Flaschennacken.
Weiß doch jeder.
Flaschennacken, Alter.
Ja, ich weiß.
Pains Champ.
Euer Rechner ist nur so stark wie das schwächste Glied in ihm.
Er hat Glied gesagt.
Daher werdet ihr von viel Stellen hören,
Grafikkarte X mit Prozessor Y solltet ihr nicht kombinieren,
weil ihr dann entweder einen Bottleneck auf eurer Grafikkarte oder auf eurem Prozessor habt.
Und ja, tatsächlich, der Bottleneck existiert.
Allerdings kann man ihn gar nicht vermeiden.
Die Frage ist nur, wo wollt ihr euren Bottleneck haben?
Sobald ihr grafisch anspruchsvoll...
Auf dem Mutterbrett will ich das Bottleneck.
...spielst, epische AAA-Titel mit vielen Details,
im besten Fall auch noch alles auf Ultra und 8K schraubt,
dann wird selbst eine 2080 Ti und auch eine Titan RTX zum Bottleneck.
Denn das sind einfach Szenarien, bei denen die Grafikkarte extrem viel Arbeit hat.
Ihr könnt den Bottleneck also nicht vermeiden.
Und viel mehr noch ist er sogar eher wünschend.
Man kann halt gucken, dass es vom Verhältnis her passt.
Einfach, weil ihr dann wisst, dass ihr eure Grafikkarte zu 100 Prozent auslastet.
Bei solchen Titeln werdet ihr auch selten über 60 bis 70 FPS kommen,
was dafür natürlich völlig ausreicht.
Spielt ihr aber competitive Spiele, bei denen es um Reaktionszeiten geht,
dann sieht das Ganze wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Hier stellen Pros in der Regel die Settings extrem weit runter
und Hardcore-Gamer gehen sogar auf Auflösungen, die meinem Herz weh tun.
Nämlich 800x...
Ja, guckt euch mal die CS-Pro-Settings an.
Die spielen teilweise wirklich 800x600.
600 stretched oder so was.
Und Leute, ich meine, wir haben nicht mehr 2006.
Full HD muss doch drin sein.
Dadurch, dass die Grafikkarte nicht mehr so viele Details berechnen muss,
wird der Prozessor in jedem Fall zum Bottleneck werden.
Also wenn du den FFZ-Audio-Kompressor aktivierst,
dann wird der Stream eigentlich lauter.
Zumindest hört er sich ein bisschen breiter an.
Und einfach so viele Bilder, wie er kann,
und die Grafikkarte langweilt sich in diesem grafisch weniger anspruchsvollen...
Ach so, deaktiviert. Ja, deaktiviert mein ich. Du hast recht, deaktiviert.
... und GPU-Kombinationen, die man vermeiden sollte.
Ich würde auch keinen AMD FX6300 mit einer RTX 2080 Ti kombinieren,
einfach weil die CPU hier so schlecht ist, dass das tatsächlich sein kann,
dass moderne Titel stellenweise nur noch sehr ruckelig laufen.
Ein Bottleneck werdet ihr aber mit jeder Kombination haben,
auch mit einer RTX 2080 Ti und einem Intel Core i9-10900...
Nein, man muss halt...
Der Witz ist halt, man muss halt einfach gucken, dass es im Verhältnis passt.
Das ist ja, glaube ich, jetzt nichts Neues.
Nummer 5.
Ja, ey!
Das ist so, aber es ist nicht relevant.
Du hast theoretisch verringerte Lebensdauer, wenn du deine CPU übertaktest.
Aber praktisch gesehen, wenn du nicht gerade der Auer bist,
der seine CPUs auf 8 GHz übertaktet und die dabei
nahe dem absoluten Nullpunkt bringt,
werden deine CPUs dich trotzdem locker überleben.
Ach so, ja, und natürlich, wenn man es einfach übertaktet mit gleicher Spannung,
dann macht es keinen großen Unterschied.
Also sprich, man muss...
Bei Intel ist halt, wenn man die Dinge übertaktet,
musst du auch ein bisschen mehr Spannung geben.
Und da leidet natürlich die Lebensdauer theoretisch drunter.
Praktisch gesehen, mir ist bis heute, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
mir ist bis heute noch nicht eine CPU verreckt.
Noch nie.
Ich glaube, hätte ich meinen ersten Pentium 90 noch,
der würde heute noch gehen.
Und hätte ich den durchlaufen lassen, seit 1900, frag mich nicht, 95 oder so,
hätte ich den durchlaufen lassen bis heute, der würde immer noch leben.
Und mein Pentium 2, den ich danach hatte, den ich von 400 auf 500 MHz übertaktet,
übrigens meine, damals habe ich mich wie der krasseste Hacker gefühlt.
Ich hatte einen Pentium 2 400 und du konntest damals relativ einfach ins Bios gehen
und den Frontside-Bus hochstellen um ein paar MHz.
Dann war die CPU am Ende 450, 450 MHz schnell und der Frontside-Bus ein bisschen schneller.
Und ich habe mich wie der ultra Hacker gefühlt damals
und ich hatte Schiss, dass mein PC gleich schmilzt.
Deswegen habe ich am Anfang immer das Ding übertaktet,
dann Windows, was waren das, 95, 890 gestartet, irgendwas gemacht
und danach wieder neu gestartet und wieder runtergetaktet,
weil ich Angst hatte, er geht kaputt.
Aber was natürlich kompletter Blödsinn ist, irgendwann habe ich das auch gecheckt
und habe es halt einfach auf 450 stehen lassen.
Aber ich kam mir wie der ultra Hacker-Man vor, als ich damals mein Pentium 2 übertaktet habe.
Da war ich aber überlegt, wann war das Pentium 2 400, wann kam das Ding raus?
97, ok.
Ok, 97.
Das heißt, sagen wir mal 98 vielleicht eher.
Ich habe Half-Life 1 gespielt, das weiß ich noch.
Aber 98, da war ich 14.
Da war ich 14 und da kam ich bald wie der ächzlichste Übertaktungs-Hacker-Man vor,
als ich den Pentium 2 übertaktet habe.
Die Pentium 2, die sahen ja auch noch,
das waren die einzigen CPUs, die so komisch auf so einer komischen Karte drauf waren.
Davor sahen die CPUs bei Intel normal aus
und ich glaube, es gab auch noch Pentium 3 und danach sahen die CPUs normal aus.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, was sich Intel gedacht hat bei dieser Geschichte hier.
Keine Ahnung.
Genau, da hat sie so eine fette CPU-Karte auf deiner Mainboard sitzen.
Hab ich bis heute nicht gecheckt, was das gebracht hat.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also wie gesagt, ja, theoretisch praktisch keine Auswirkungen.
Ach so, ist euch denn jetzt schon mal eine CPU verreckt? Hab ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen im Chat.
Irgendjemand hat geschrieben, ihm ist schon mal ein 4790 oder so verreckt.
Aber wie gesagt, mir ist noch nie eine CPU verreckt.
Das ist doch Werbung für Vengeance Pro, oder?
Ist der gesponsert bei Corsair? Wie oft er Corsair zeigt? Alter, das kann doch nicht sein.
Von wem ist der... Okay, okay.
Irgendjemand, da ist was im Busch. Ich erkenne das, wenn ich sehe.
Ich hab, ich hab mein Klo übertaktet letztens.
Und ihr kennt mein Klo, oder?
Ja, das ist mein Klo.
Das ist mein Klo.
Und ihr kennt mein Klo und ihr wisst, dass das nicht, dass das durchaus sein kann, wenn ich das sage.
Also müsst ihr zum Beispiel nicht nur den Takt hochschrauben, sondern darüber hinaus auch noch die Spannung und vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen Wert.
Das wiederum hat zur Folge, dass die CPU heißer wird.
Und genau hier werden euch Leute sagen, dass das am Ende dazu führen kann, dass die Lebensdauer eurer Hardware reduziert wird.
Und dieser Mythos ist zwar wahr, allerdings spielt er kaum noch eine Rolle.
Denn gerade Prozessoren haben eine Lebensdauer von 10 Jahren und mehr.
Wenn ihr jetzt einen Prozessor bis ans Limit übertaktet, dann kann es sein, dass sich die Lebensdauer um 10% reduziert.
Ihr könnt das Teil dann also nur noch 9 Jahre lang nutzen.
Und jetzt frage ich euch...
Genau, das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Letztendlich überlebt das, überlebt euch die CPU trotzdem.
Gleiche CPU wie vor 9 Jahren verbaut.
Ich glaube, die Frage beantwortet sich eigentlich ganz gut von selbst.
Habt ihr auch diesen einen Besserwisser im Freundeskreis, der euch...
Okay, das waren jetzt ziemlich banale Sachen, ziemlich naheliegende Sachen.
Und bei einer Sache bin ich mir jetzt aus technischer Sicht gar nicht so sicher, ob das stimmt.
Aber die Erklärung passt an sich schon.
Ob der CPU-Takt angibt, wie viele Instruktionen der CPU durchführen kann.
Ich glaube eher, wenn man mal ganz pingelig ist, ist der CPU-Takt eine feste Größe,
die mit irgendeinem Taktgeber, Kristall, Bus-Takt, Oszillator erzeugt wird.
Und eigentlich eher darum geht quasi der Zyklus zwischen Befehle abarbeiten, neue Befehle abrufen, Befehle abarbeiten.
Ich glaube, wenn man ganz pingelig ist, trifft es das eher.
Aber die Erklärung, wie viel die CPU in der Sekunde abarbeiten kann, ist glaube ich sinnvoller.
Ich bin mir da selbst gar nicht so genau sicher, wie ich CPU-Takt jetzt genau definieren würde.
Aber auf jeden Fall mehr ist gut.
Aber mehr ist nicht immer gleich schneller.
Das hatte ich auch mal in einem Video,
und das nur, weil die CPU schneller taktet, sie nicht automatisch unbedingt gewisse Sachen schneller machen muss.
Weil es ist ja auch ganz klar, dass es nicht...
Man muss sich ja mal überlegen, es gibt Instruktionen, die brauchen zwei Takte, die brauchen drei Takte,
die brauchen einen Takt, es ist ja unterschiedlich, deswegen kann das ja schon mal gar nicht sein.
Ja genau, aber dass die Takt-Frequenz die Anzahl der Takte misst, ist klar.
Was versteht man genau unter einem Takt?
Weil das Abarbeiten von einem Befehl kann es nicht wirklich sein.
Du hast die meisten CPU-Instruktionen, oder die bisschen advancederen, die brauchen zwei, drei Zyklen.
Ich glaube so einfach ist das gar nicht zu definieren.
Keine Ahnung, ist auch wurscht.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Kannst du dich noch an die alten PCs erinnern, wo man die Takt-Frequenz am Tower per Boost hat?
Klar, natürlich kann ich mich daran erinnern.
Boost, das war eher zu Zeiten von 486, da konntest du quasi runtertacken auf die halbe Takt-Frequenz,
dass ältere Software annehmbar langsam gelaufen ist.
Kennt noch jemand von euch das erste Commandos-Game?
Äh, zwei, meine ich, zwei, das da.
War das Commandos? Kennt das noch jemand?
Das war so ein Taktik-Stells-Game.
Und diese hier sieht man genau, das sind die Sichtkegel der Gegner.
So, und die Sache war die, das Game ist auf Takt-Frequenz programmiert gewesen.
Und du hattest dann beispielsweise Gegner, die sind halt rumgelaufen und haben halt das Ergebnis,
die haben das Gebiet gescannt, wo du mit deinen Helden durchgelaufen bist und du konntest das Spiel
auf einem Pentium 2 400 beispielsweise nicht spielen, weil es gab eine Map, da ist ein Boot durchgefahren
und das Boot hat halt in alle Richtungen diesen Sichtkegel gehabt und du bist dann quasi da langgelaufen
und im Pentium 400 ist das Boot dann so langgefahren.
Du konntest den Boot überhaupt nicht mehr ausweichen,
es sei denn du hattest irgendwie StarCraft Pro-Gamer-Reflexe gehabt.
Das war ein bisschen fail, ja.
Deswegen ist es keine gute Idee, Sachen an Takt-Frequenz zu koppeln, ey.
Boah, was denn ist das? Home Lab Tour, das meint es zu.
Ok, was haben wir denn für Videos zu gucken? Ich hab ein paar Sachen schon mal aufgemacht.
Ähm, juckt mich nicht.
Ja, ich hab ein paar Sachen aufgemacht, die man sich angucken könnte.
Also, was gucken wir uns denn an?
Metro Top-Plays, oh nee, da dreh ich durch, wenn ich Metro Top-Plays angucken muss.
Wobei, wir können uns Metro Top-Plays angucken.
Hacker breaks down 26 Hacking-Scenes from Movie.
Das ist bestimmt grausam, aber warum geht das 21 Minuten?
Oh, please, no.
Sowas gibt es doch heute noch nur über PCI halt.
Xeon-Phi, äh, was?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was du meinst jetzt gerade.
Auf was bezieht sich das hier?
Du meinst, so wie der Pentium 2, so Einschubkarten?
Ah, gut, heute hast du halt Grafikkarten.
Grafikkarten sind ja im Prinzip auch...
...Computing-Power, die da im Steckkarten-Format, so.
Ok, ok, mal gucken.
Das wird grausam, Leute, das wird grausam, ich weiß jetzt schon.
Bisschen leise.
Moment, jetzt hab ich am Anfang nicht verpasst.
Aber da kann ich überhaupt nicht dran erinnern.
Ok, ok, mal gucken, ob das jetzt zu laut oder zu leise ist.
Mal schauen.
Ich find das immer geil, wenn die in Filmen dann immer davor sitzen, als sind die Leute so übelst krasse.
Ich soll mal sagen, so krasse, wie soll man das sagen?
So überkommunikative, aufgedrehte Leute, die dann vorm Rechner sitzen, so nach dem Motto, ähm...
Haha, jetzt hab ich dich gleich erwischt hier.
Ah, du Sau, ich heck dich jetzt voll, jetzt willst du so krass...
Oh, Hex, oh, Hex, oh, Hex.
Das ist, das ist in Filmen immer so, Alter.
Das ist so dumm.
Und dann hast du in Filmen immer irgendwelche komischen grafischen Dinger, die absolut nichts damit zu tun haben, wie das in Wirklichkeit aussieht.
Erstens sitzt du, also erst, unabhängig davon, man könnte sagen, im Prinzip ist es ja mehr oder weniger zum größten Teil Programmieren.
Ja, Netzwerktechnik programmieren, fassen wir uns mal unter Programmieren zusammen, so.
Ehrlich gesagt, sitzt du da, guckst dir auf der einen Seite irgendwelche Netzwerk-Dumps in Wireshark an.
Und auf der anderen Seite, ähm, sitzt du da und überlegst dir, warum funktioniert der Scheiß nicht, den ich programmiert hab.
Und bist dann überlegen und änderst ab und zu mal ein Zeichen, lässt das Ganze nochmal laufen, gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Hast noch ein Terminal auf und probierst da irgendwelche Sachen aus.
Das sieht halt absolut nicht spektakulär aus, die Realität, ja.
Und wenn mal einer wirklich der richtige Hacker-Man werden will, dann wartet ihr mal bis euer Chef reinkommt und sagt, ich bin grad, äh, ich mach grad wichtige Sachen.
I'm in.
Wir starten jetzt die Cybernuke, Leute.
Ja, ist doch ein bisschen Linux, was ist denn das überhaupt, Linux, das ist auf jeden Fall Linux-Kernel, Group-Info.
Das ist irgendwelche User-Rechte-Verwaltung oder so.
By the way, jetzt weiß ich, warum ihr das bekannt vorkommt.
Die Telekom hatte, die Telekom hat Code aus Hacker-Typer verwendet für eine, für eine, für Werbung für sich.
Die Telekom hatte mal einen Werbe-Tweet abgesetzt, wo sie geworben hat um Bewerbung, Bewerber.
Und hat so ein kleines Werbe-Filmchen reingeschnitten mit Leuten, die jetzt quasi bei der Telekom, das ist das, wo die gesagt haben, ich soll mich bewerben, ja.
Da haben die quasi ein kleines Werbe-Filmchen gemacht, wo sie reingeschrieben haben, wo sie dann gezeigt haben so,
Hallo, ich bin, keine Ahnung, Jessica, ich bin Programmierer bei der Telekom.
Und dann haben die halt gezeigt, was sie angeblich programmiert und da hatten sie halt einen Ausschnitt aus Hacker-Typer drin.
Und hat auch noch, und hat auch noch falsch copy-pasted.
Die hatten einen Ausschnitt irgendwo hier drin und haben dann quasi das hier soweit copy-pasted und dann das hier soweit.
Komplett random und komplett unzusammenhängend.
Wenn noch nicht mal das Werbe-Video irgendwie die Realität widerspiegelt.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter, Hacker-Hacker-Mans.
Das ist ziemlich sicher C, ja, ja.
Das ist so schwachsinnig, vor allem diese komische Leiste.
V1, es sieht voll krass technisch aus, ja.
Hat aber Assembling-Crypto-Algorithm.
Okay, aber das ist hier Big Brain KI, die für mich irgendwelche Verschlüsselungssachen zusammenbaut.
Lass ihn doch mal ausreden, stoppt doch nicht die ganze Zeit.
Richtig, richtig.
Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen HTML, aber trotzdem, zu 90% wird das so aussehen, ja.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt HTML.
Hat er da gerade gedappt?
Ist er gerade voll hier krass am Hacker-Dappen, so irgendwie?
Warum sind die Hacker in den Filmen immer so extrem von sich und ihrem Kram so krass extrovertiert überzeugte Hacker-Mans?
So sind die meisten Leute überhaupt nicht.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich glaube, die wenigsten werden dir sagen, so nach dem Motto, das ist alles Shit, aber mein richtig krasser, selbst programmierter Kick-Ass-Algorithmus, der hat das jetzt geregelt.
Übrigens, diese Sache mit Ampeln und Verkehrszeichen und sowas, das ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Da habe ich, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt gerade aktuell ist.
Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mal einen Beitrag drüber gesehen, das könnte sogar ein Talk von irgendeiner Sicherheitskonferenz gewesen sein, ist aber schon ein paar Jahre her,
dass tatsächlich, und da ging es halt um Freedom-Land, dass dort einige dieser Traffic-Control-System-Dinger, dass du die wirklich übers Internet erreichen konntest und dort wirklich Sachen schalten konntest.
Also das ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt und mich würde nicht wundern, wenn wir hier vielleicht, wobei, nee, in Deutschland kann das nicht passieren, weil in Deutschland sind die Dinger wahrscheinlich so alt, die hätten noch nicht mal Internet zu, also die hätten noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit, ans Internet angeschlossen zu werden.
Okay, ich habe mir das noch nie im Detail angeschaut, aber ich halte das für durchaus logisch, dass das geht.
Nicht so, vielleicht nicht so, wie man es hier zeigt, aber ja.
Ist meistens SPS in Deutsch, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Warum sind die Hacker in so einem Film immer die übelsten Spass, ich weiß nicht, so nach dem Motto, ah gib mir noch kurz Zeit, ich hab's fast, ich hab's fast, du hast noch 10 Sekunden, jawoll ich mach das in 5 Sekunden, super Hacker, krass am Start, das ist so unrealistisch.
Aber gut, ich verstehe, ich verstehe, dass echte Security Geschichten in Filmen nicht sonderlich spannend sind.
Man muss ja auch sagen, das war in Mr. Robot teilweise nicht schlecht, wie sie das gezeigt haben, auch wenn Mr. Robot ab der zweiten Hälfte der ersten Staffel, was das angeht, ziemlich, egal, aber die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel, die war nicht schlecht, ganz gut.
Aber selbst da haben sie das ja auch sehr verkürzt und beschleunigt gezeigt alles.
Also, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es so den Ultra Big Brain Hacker gibt, der sich an ein System setzt, dass er noch nie vorher irgendwie, an dem er noch nie vorher dran war und dort 3-4 Tasten drückt und dann geht die Tür auf.
Solche Dinger, das ist Schwachsinn. Du brauchst erstmal ne Zeit dich umzugucken, ok, wo bist du hier überhaupt drauf gelandet, was sind hier für Sachen drauf, was kann man hier machen.
Also einfach mal, ich bin mal kurz für 2 Minuten im Security Raum und programmier mal schnell meinen eigenen Keylogger.
Ja, die Musik dabei. Ich meine, es ist immerhin ein Terminal.
Das erinnert mich an Folgendes. Kennt ihr das? Wartet mal. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das hier installiert habe, aber wenn ihr mal wieder richtig krasse Hacker aussehen wollt, dann müsst ihr das hier nehmen.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich hab das installiert. Wartet mal. Wenn ich installiere, ist schnell, das geht. Das geht schnell.
Auf. Vm, geh an. Übrigens, ich hab meinen 3D-Drucker jetzt gelevelt. War das Hollywood? Ich glaub Hollywood war das.
Wow, was muss ich denn alles installieren? Erstmal Pearl, erstmal Pearl installieren. Ok, ich installiere mal kurz das halbe Internet.
Das, ey guck mal, das hier sieht für die meisten Leute doch schon Hacker-Man genug aus, oder? So, machen wir hier mal zu. Hollywood.
Jawoll, Hacker-Man am Start. Also wenn ihr mal richtig Hacker-Man aussehen wollt, Hollywood installieren. I'm in.
Im Butterbrett. Ja, das ist super. Also es gab noch was anderes. Ich hab vergessen, es gab noch irgendein anderes Tool, das so ähnlich war.
Es gab noch irgendein anderes. Aber vergessen, wie das heißt. Zumindest Hollywood ist top. Also wenn ihr mal wieder übelste Hacker-Man aussehen wollt, dann das.
Ok, weiter, weiter im Text. Gutes Video dazu tatsächlich aus einer Serie. Ok, zeig mal her. Eine Minute. Wehe, das ist Mist hier.
Dann gibt's instant kick a bun, de-subscription und keine Ahnung, alles. Ok.
Was ist denn?
Ok, did in vorne Lulz, das ist tatsächlich nicht so weit von der Realität entfernt.
Das stimmt, ja.
Naja, die Erklärung ist nicht verkehrt. Dass das mit Filmen nichts zu tun hat, haben wir ja auch schon oft genug gesehen. Also wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Ist das Freddy? Rocket Jump Freddy? Ein bisschen jüngere Variante von ihm.
Ich weiß gar nicht, dass der in den Filmen mitgespielt hat. Oder ist das ein Clip von ihm? Ich weiß auch immer. Ich guck mal weiter.
Die Musik dabei.
Vor allem, vor allem das haben die auch immer in Filmen gerne. Die sitzen dann in irgendeiner Garage oder in irgendeinem Fabrikgelände und daneben steht dann irgendeiner und guckt ihnen zu.
So nach dem Motto, ich will jetzt sehen, wie du jetzt hier die krasse Sachen häckst. Kompletter Blödsinn, Alter. Die meisten sitzen daheim vor ihrem Rechner, haben die Klimaanlage an und basteln vor sich hin.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, viele Hexer sind da oldschool, die sind halt im IRC mit ein paar anderen oder so. Aber wahrscheinlich heute auch eher Discord.
Das haben die auch immer gerne, dass dann jemand vom Rechner sitzt und sagt ihr Motto, er kommt jetzt hier rein, gerade habe ich ihn nochmal ausgesperrt.
Oh nee, er versucht es jetzt, er versucht es an einer anderen Stelle. So, oh scheiße, oh scheiße, er ist gleich drin. Es gibt keinen Progress, der irgendwie anzeigt, so nach dem Motto, Angreifer eingedrungen. 1%, 2%, 3%, 4%. Kompletter Schwachsinn.
Dazu fällt mir eine geile Sache ein. Wir hatten mal einen auf der Arbeit, ich würde sagen, er hat Java Zeug kompiliert den ganzen Tag, was andere programmiert haben. Und dann hat er es getestet.
Das war einer, der hat sich extrem schlau gefunden. Der hat mal was gebastelt, was automatisch sein Java Zeug klont und kompiliert für ihn und dann ein paar Tests durchführt.
Zumindest hat er dann das mal vorgestellt, hat er mir mal gezeigt und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, was machst du denn jetzt, wenn sich die Stelle ändert oder wenn sich was ändert, wo er die Sachen herzieht.
Da hat er mich gefragt, wie gehst du denn mit Fehlern um. Und da meint er, das Skript ist selbstheilend. Das Skript ist selbstheilend, das repariert sich dann selbst.
Da hatte ich irgendwie meine Zweifel dran, dass wenn das Repo sich ändert, wo das liegt, dass sein Skript auf einmal in der Lage ist, rauszufinden, wo das neue Repo liegt.
Das ist ein selbstheilendes Skript.
Oh, Hexed, Moment, Moment, das war ein Hexed oder da war ein G drinne? Und, ja, Moment. Ja, ist es jetzt Hex oder nicht?
Extended Hex, was ist das? Hex 64, Hex 26, Hex 26, das ist jetzt das Next Level Shit, Alter.
Das müssen wir mal finden. Es ist nicht Hex, es ist Hex 26.
Das ist kein Hex.
Ja, wenigstens nach das.
Die Rechner damals gar nicht hingekriegt haben.
Hackers, es ist so ein merkwürdiger Film. Eigentlich ist es totaler Crap, aber lustigerweise genießt dieser Film bei echten Hexers irgendwie einen gewissen Kultstatus.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau warum.
Mit Sonnenbrille. Und was macht die Tape Library da?
Irgendwie im Keller besitzt wird da. Ich glaube, dass viele dieser Hacker-Klischees tatsächlich aus diesem Film auch kommen.
Ich mein, Keller mit Sonnenbrille, das ist schon so. Mehr Klischee-Hacker geht gar nicht.
Du bist zu jung. Was meinst du denn, wie alt ich bin?
Okay, es ist in seinem Zimmer, aber es ist dunkel und die Sonnenbrille hat er auf. Also mehr Hacker geht kaum.
Warum macht es einen Sound, wenn es etwas aufbaut?
Das war auch mal eine Zeit lang immer sehr beliebt in Filmen, dass Tastaturdrücke Sounds verursacht haben.
So nach dem Motto...
Wisst ihr, wie nervig das wäre, wenn jeder Tastendruck einen Sound machen würde?
Du sitzt immer mit Sonnenbrille im Office. Ja, bei dem Wetter, wenn die Sonne reinschaltet, okay.
Aber du musst den Rollladen runter machen und dunkel machen und alle Lichter ausmachen.
Dann Sonnenbrille aufziehen, nur dann ist es original Hacker-Man.
So ein Telefon, ja.
Da bin ich jetzt 35 oder 36. Also ich bin eigentlich alt genug, dass ich das kenne.
Und ja, ich hab den Film damals auch geguckt und ich fand den Film damals auch irgendwie nice.
Aber mittlerweile kann ich nicht verstehen, warum der gerade auch bei technisch versierten Leuten so beliebt ist.
Das weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht weil es so überdreht ist und weil viele dieser ganzen Hacker-Geschichten daherkommen.
Das war aber damals wirklich ein Ding, ja.
Not impressed. Das Grill ist nicht begeistert von seinen Hacking-Fähigkeiten.
Dabei hat er gerade ihre Note besser gemacht, also könnte man sich mal zumindest ein bisschen nett sein.
Hacker-Tool.
Vor allem, was ist das für ein grausames User-Interface? Was soll man da mit machen?
Oh, es ist OS12, ja.
Was aber halt auch schon wieder geil ist. Das ist ein super geheimes, special, secure, sonst was Betriebssystem.
Und er hat ein Gerät, was er in den Server stecken kann, was zufälligerweise irgendwie in der Lage ist,
ein für ihn unbekanntes System so zu verändern, dass es Sachen macht, die er möchte.
Was auch irgendwie ein bisschen realitätsfremder ist.
Mr. Robot hat ein paar ganz gute Sachen drinne.
Flo96 BigBrain.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie es in Deutschland ist, aber ich vermute mal hier auch,
viele der Systeme im Krankenhaus, also ok, ich muss anders anfangen.
Krankenhäuser haben erstens viel Technik drinne und viel zu wenig Leute,
die sich um die Technik kümmern und teilweise uralte Technik.
Wie gesagt, ich war ja erst Ende letzten Jahres mit meiner Mutter im Krankenhaus.
Das erste, was ich gesehen habe, ist Windows XP startet.
Und da habe ich auch schon gesagt, ok, wir verlassen uns jetzt gerade drauf,
dass Windows XP uns das Leben rettet, so nach dem Otto. Aber gut, dann, es hat ja funktioniert.
Gute Leben rettet, so schlimm war es ja nicht. Vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben gesagt.
Und, dass im Krankenhaus da viele Angriffsmöglichkeiten gibt, denke ich auch.
Also wir können ja gerne mal über Altisac im kritischen Bereich reden.
Ja, ich weiß, du kennst dich in dem Bereich aus und gerade Krankenhäuser ist was,
was ich mir denke, da ist viel möglich, was halt glücklicherweise wenig passiert.
Oder vielleicht trotzdem einiges passiert, von dem man gar nichts mitkriegt.
Das ist den Typ, den er dann übelst fertig gemacht hat auf dem Flur.
Was er für ein Kacknoob ist.
Er ist auch ein Idiot.
Und seine Technologie ist extrem alt.
Er nutzt diese unvergessliche Sicherheitssoftware, die auf Windows 98 läuft.
Das ist ziemlich genau, wenn du über die meisten Krankenhäuser sprichst.
Und er soll ihre Netzwerke von Leuten wie mich schützen.
Außerdem sind die Interfaces in diesem Clip eigentlich realistisch.
Du musst dich nicht umdrehen.
Letztendlich haben wir gehört, dass eigentliche Krankenhäuser verpackt werden,
Malware und Ransomware installiert haben und sogar einige Teile geschlossen werden,
einfach weil die Sicherheitssoftware und das alte System nicht funktioniert.
NCIS.
Ist das die Cybernuke?
Ist das die Szene mit...
Nee, das war Castle, glaube ich, mit der Cybernuke.
Das ist, finde ich, immer noch die beste Hacker-Szene aller Zeiten.
Die Cybernuke.
Da guckt euch die Fenster an.
Sieht fast aus, wie man das wirklich...
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das hat doch gewisse Ähnlichkeiten gehabt gerade, oder?
Das hat doch gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Das ist ja so...
Obwohl ich sagen muss, das ist schon wieder lustig irgendwie.
Ich habe noch nie so kalt wie das.
Stopp den Pop-Up.
Das ist ja so krass. Wobei ich sagen muss, das ist schon wieder lustig irgendwie. Vor allem, ich irgendwie, ich kann mich nichts erinnern oder mir fällt keine Situation ein, wo jemand da sitzt und aktiv dabei ist und sagt so, oh shit, we're getting hacked. Eigentlich ist es eher so, wenn man sich mal die aktuellen Sachen anguckt, wo irgendwelche Daten abgezogen werden oder so.
Eigentlich ist es eher so, oh fuck, vor einem halben Jahr hat einer bei uns Daten geklaut und wir haben es jetzt erst bemerkt.
Naja, also wenn man nicht, wenn man nicht den Upsender mit der IP plotten kann, man kann einfach seinen Service vom Netz trennen, dann ist es vorbei.
Da muss ich nicht seine IP blacklisten. Oder man blacklistet einfach alles. Aber die einfachste Variante, also die Variante, die auf jeden Fall funktioniert, ist das da? Die geht immer. Also wenn gar nichts hilft, die geht definitiv.
Dann ist vorbei mit Hexor. Da ist natürlich auch vorbei mit Zugriff von allen anderen auch, aber dann ist auf jeden Fall die Sache geritzt.
Alternativ, man kann auch einfach den Switchport runterfahren, den Server ausschalten, den Netzwerkding runter, irgendwas. Man kann alles blocken. Man blockt nicht gezielt immer nur eine Absender IP, wenn das irgendein Botnetz ist oder so. Das wäre beknackt.
Oder man verwendet ExpressVPN, dann ist alles gut. Oder NordVPN oder ein Schwachsinn, das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Ping 1.6. Das ist upgraded. Normaler Ping tut es nicht mehr.
Das ist wirklich nicht so weit von der Realität weg. Es ist glaube ich nicht so oft Russland. Was ist denn beliebt? Irgendwelche Inseldinger.
Eine ganze Weile weiß ich noch, dass Zeeland diese Ölplattform geworben hat mit so bulletproof Hosting. Kennt ihr Zeeland? Das ist so eine Ölplattform, die glaube ich irgendwo vor England steht.
Aber weit genug vor England weg, ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es das gar nicht mehr. Die weit genug von England weg ist, dass sie in internationalen Gewässern ist.
Und dann ist irgendein Typ mal dahin gefahren, hat gesagt, der ist jetzt der König von Zeeland und hat seinen eigenen Staat ausgerufen auf der Ölplattform.
Ah ja, da ist Zeeland. Sieht nach einem äußerst einladenden Platz aus, muss man ja sagen. Und die haben mal eine Weile so Hosting-Geschichten angeboten.
Beliebt sie Russland, Ukraine, Moldavien, Hongkong? Aha. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass irgendwelche Insel-Sachen sehr beliebt sind. Am Arsch der Welt.
Ja. Ja und die haben auch eine Zeit lang mal Geld damit verdient, indem sie Adelstitel von Zeeland verkauft haben.
Also wer schon immer mal Lord, Lady, Graf, sonst was, off Zeeland sein wollte, der konnte sich das bei denen kaufen.
Aber das hat das Ding hat nie einer anerkannt.
Ich habe etwas im Chat übersehen, muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Ah ok, habe ich nichts übersehen, passt.
Was für eine Überraschung.
Oh guck mal, das haben die auch immer gerne in Filmen, dass sie dann so Sachen auf irgendwelche riesigen Monitorwänden anzeigen. Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Du willst es bei den Leuten auf dem Monitor haben, die irgendwie Ahnung davon haben oder die gerade was machen. Was brauchst du in einem Raum voller BWL Leute, vor einer monitorischen Wand, wo ein Editor angezeigt wird?
Was interessiert einen Raum voller BWL Leute, irgendwie ein Editor auf einer Monitorwand, der irgendwie auch komisch.
Ist das ein Mac? Soll das überall ein Mac sein?
Ich kann überhaupt nicht, ich verstehe überhaupt, was wollen die uns da überhaupt gerade zeigen? Ah hier, guck mal, da hat man was erkannt.
Also erstmal, weibliche Hacker zu dieser Zeit, das gab es nicht so viel, aber ich meine, das ist ein Film. Decompiling Sourcecode. Warum soll ich das decompilen, wenn ich schon den Sourcecode habe, das ist ein bescheuertes Titel.
Ok, ok, ist die compile zu, ok, ja, ergibt schon, ergibt irgendwo Sinn.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das machst du nicht einfach mal in 2 Minuten, also ja, irgendwas decompilen machst du in 2 Minuten, aber dann zu checken, was es macht eher nicht in 2 Minuten.
Das ist die Cyber Nuke, das ist die beste Hacking Szene aller Zeiten, ich glaube, dass das die Cyber Nuke ist.
Oder ist es was anderes? Das ist so fein. Vor allem der Alarm dabei, Alarm.
Da ploppt ein Bildschirm auf mit irgendeiner Feuersirene und da steht Fire Vault Breach drauf, alles klar.
Ja, und wie gesagt, diese mit der Sache, Hilfe, wir werden gehackt, aber ich kann Ihnen verlangen, das größte Problem ist eigentlich eher aktuell, dass irgendjemand irgendwo Daten abzieht und das 1. halbes Jahr später merkt.
Also mir fällt jetzt keine Situation ein, wo du live dabei sitzt, so nach dem Motto, wir werden gerade gehackt, ich kann ihn aufhalten, ist irgendwie voll vorbei an der Realität.
Aber gut, das ist natürlich absichtlich übertrieben gemacht.
Ja, aber das kommt nicht wirklich oft vor, also wenn du wirklich gerade live dabei sitzt, wo irgendwie einer gerade was probiert, da muss schon viel Glück haben.
Fire Vault 1, 2, 3, guck mal hier, die haben ja, vielleicht sollten die sich ihre Fire Vault Regeln mal überdenken. Vielleicht sollten sie lieber eine hin machen mit ordentlichen Regeln anstatt vier, die nur Schrott drin haben.
Moment, Moment, die wichtig, das beste aus dieser Szene haben die gar nicht drin. Cyber Nuke, das Ende müssen wir uns jetzt nochmal angucken. Moment, das Ende, nur das Ende.
Nur das Ende, nur das Ende, wartet mal.
Gleich, gleich.
Die Musik, Alter.
Ich kann mich immer wegpissen bei dieser Szene, Alter.
Ich kann mich bei dieser Szene immer fest, das Cyber Nuke, das ist so schlecht.
Das ist so der Fast schlecht.
Das ist so der Fast beklagt.
Ihr habt im Kibana gesehen, dass was los ist, okay, verstehe. Aber das ist echt, das ist die beste Hacking Szene aller Zeiten, Alter.
Übrigens, die Sachen, die sie in Matrix gezeigt haben, die waren gar nicht schlecht. Die waren natürlich verkürzt, ihr wisst ja, das ist eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsfilme.
Die sind gar nicht so schlecht gewesen, die Sachen, die sie drin gezeigt haben. Die haben meistens irgendwelche Terminal Action gezeigt, so wie es halt in Wirklichkeit ist, nur halt sehr stark komprimiert.
Wobei, Matrix 2.3 hätte kein Mensch gebraucht und jetzt die Matrix Neuauflage, die jetzt demnächst irgendwann anfängt, die jetzt irgendwann mal kommen soll, die braucht wahrscheinlich auch keiner, aber der erste Matrix ist eines der geilsten Filme ever.
Und ich finde, was eines der Sachen, die gerade bei Matrix auch dazu beiträgt, dass der ziemlich gut gealtert ist, ist, dass der zu einer Zeit entstanden ist, wo du teilweise schon CGI gemacht hast, aber vieles in Matrix ist nicht CGI.
Also wie gesagt, diese ganze Helikoptergeschichte ist wie gesagt vor einer Leinwand gedreht worden und sowas, also da, wo sie Morpheus befreien mit der Minigun und so.
Das haben die gedreht, natürlich post-process schon ein bisschen, aber das haben die wirklich gedreht mit dem Helikopter und einer Leinwand dahinter und so.
Also vieles an Matrix ist nicht CGI und auch diese, die Bullet Time, da ist viel weniger CGI bei, als man denkt.
Und ich glaube, deswegen ist der erste Matrix 5 auch so gut gealtert und die nächsten zwei nicht so gut, obwohl die einen ganzen paar Jahre später rausgekommen sind.
Also ihr müsst euch mal das Making-of angucken, also bei dieser ganzen CGI sind Computer-generated Images, also gerenderte Sachen am Computer im Film und in Spielen und überall halt.
Also Spiele sind halt nur CGI, wenn du es so willst.
Zumindest die Bullet Time-Szene aus Matrix, da ist nur ganz kleiner Teil davon post-process CGI, die haben einfach einen riesen Ring an Kameras aufgestellt.
Und das einzige CGI, glaube ich, an dieser Bullet Time ist, neben den Pistolenkugeln mal außen vor, ist der Hintergrund.
Und der Hintergrund ist gar nicht mal wirklich CGI, der Hintergrund ist quasi mehr oder weniger reingreen-screened, dass die da auf dem Häuserdach sind, weil die sind natürlich nicht auf dem Häuserdach gewesen.
Aber ansonsten, dieser ganze Bullet Time-Shot an sich, wo die Kamera um Neotroom herumfährt und er da seine Move macht, das haben die eins zu eins so aufgenommen.
Also sprich, den haben die da wirklich hingehauen und er hat da seine Moves gemacht und die Kameras, das waren dann irgendwie 400 Kameras, irgendwie viele Sachen, die haben halt wirklich Bilder von dem im Kreis aufgenommen.
Also das Matrix-Making-Off, wie gesagt, interessiere mich normalerweise nicht so sehr für Filme, aber das Matrix-Making-Off war wirklich gut.
Und der ist halt zu einer Zeit anstanden, wo die Sachen noch nicht so extrem CGI-heavy waren.
Das Einzige, was komplett CGI ist in Matrix, sind die Flug-Szenen mit dem Raumschiff, aber das sind halt wie viel zwei Minuten im ganzen Film oder sowas.
Aber auch diese, vieles der anderen Sachen ist zum größten Teil echt, so blöd es klingt, weil Matrix ja gerade ein Film ist, wo es gerade um die Computer-generierte Welt geht, ist der erste Matrix-Film doch viel weniger CGI, als man denkt.
Und da hat sich ja, die haben sich ja auch teilweise Knochen gebrochen dabei, weil die halt wirklich sich quer durch die U-Bahn geflogen sind und sowas.
Und wusstet ihr warum Neo im ersten Matrix-Film so wenig kickt? Also Neo schlägt zum größten Teil nur mit den Fäusten. Neo kickt so wenig, weil er sich seinen Knick, seinen Hals verletzt hat.
Und die Szenen, wo er irgendwelche Dritte macht, erst ganz am Ende drehen konnten, weil sein Hals erst heilen musste.
Deswegen ist Neo ein so geiler Boxer, der kaum kickt, weil Keanu Reeves verletzten Hals hatte. Ich weiß, cool story, Max.
Und am Ende konnten sie das dann nachholen und ein paar Szenen, deswegen kickt er auch, wenn er kickt, so langsam, weil sein Hals verletzt ist. Egal, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Hacking into a power grid.
Sogar eine echte IP verwendet, die es geben könnte.
Trinity heißt die. Ich hab keinen anderen Film mehr gesehen, wo die jemals mitgespielt hat. Ich glaub, das ist der einzige Film. Nein, die hat bestimmt nicht nur den Film gemacht. Ich kenn keinen anderen Film, wo die dabei war.
Keanu Reeves ist ja nur wirklich in jedem zweiten Film teilweise gewesen. Und Morphoals auch. Ich hab jetzt vergessen, wie heißt der Morphoals Dude? Der hat auch viele Filme gemacht, aber Trinity hab ich in keinem anderen Film gesehen.
Barons Fishbone, genau. Ja, das ist relativ realistisch, kann man nix sagen.
Und übrigens auch noch Fun Fact, Matrix, dass das alles so grün aussieht. Also ich weiß es nur vom ersten, es gibt eine GitHub-Repo für SSH Nuke.
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie Matrix-Verarschung, oder? Script Emulate SSH Nuke Program von Matrix. Eine Sache zum Thema Matrix, dass das alles so grün aussieht.
Ich kann das nur zum ersten Matrix-Film sagen, weil die anderen hab ich zwar geguckt, fand ich nicht gut und das Making-of hab ich nur zum ersten gesehen. Dass Matrix überall so grün ist, man denkt ja, das ist Post-Processing. Ist es nicht. Die haben wirklich die Szenen, die Leute und die Klamotten grün angemalt.
Also der hat wirklich ein grünes Hemd an. Also vielleicht haben sie für Matrix 2 und 3 dann rein Post-Process gemacht, ich weiß es nicht, aber Matrix 1 haben die die Leute grün angemalt, die Räume grün gemacht und die Klamotten grün gemacht in der Matrix.
Also sie haben echt einen riesen Aufwand betrieben, dass es grün aussieht. Okay, der ist einfach grün angemalt. Der ist grün, das ist kein Effekt nachher, der ist grün.
Okay, das ist natürlich wieder schwachsinnig.
Also so ein durchsichtiges Telefon mit irgendwelchen Bildern und dreimal draufgeklickt, würde ich jetzt nicht als soll ich realistisch bezeichnen.
Was, es gibt in John Wick viele Querverweise auf... Echt? Hä? Wirklich?
Die Musik dabei immer, Alter!
Das hatten sie, das hatten sie in alten Filmen, hatten sie das unglaublich gerne, dass so Computerkram immer so billigstes 3D war.
So nach dem Motto, ich hacke mich jetzt in die Bank und dann musst du irgendwie so ein 3D-Tresor knacken. Zu Zeiten, wo Rechner daheim nicht mal ansatzweise in der Lage waren, solche 3D-Geschichten anzuzeigen.
Das ist gut zu sehen, ja.
Ja, ist klar, ist klar, alles klar.
Uploading Virus, done! Mal gucken, ob er jetzt das sagt, was ich auch gerade sagen will.
Ja, also die Sache ist die, ein Virus auf ein System zu bekommen, das habe ich schon 50.000 mal gesagt, aber das kann man nicht genug betonen. Ein Virus auf ein System zu bekommen, ist gar nicht mal so das Problem. Es ist auch ein Problem, aber nicht das Problem. Also spätestens wie viele Leute heute noch E-Mail-Anhänger anklicken, ist das das kleinere Problem.
Also irgendwas auf ein System drauf zu bekommen, ist das erste Problem, das kleinere Problem eigentlich. Das größte Problem ist, wie kriegst du das dazu, dass es ausgeführt wird?
Also sprich, ich könnte mir den Virus runterladen als Zip, entpacken auf meinem Desktop und es würde nichts passieren. Ich muss das Ding irgendwie ausgeführt kriegen und das ist der eigentliche Knackpunkt dabei.
Da gibt es verschiedenste Ansätze. Wie gesagt, E-Mail-Anhänge ist das einfachste, da klinken es die Leute direkt an. Es gab beispielsweise letztens unter Windows so eine Security-Lücke, was Vorschaubilder anging. Da konnte man quasi, wenn man die Datei richtig manipuliert hatte, dadurch, dass Windows versucht hat ein Vorschaubild zu generieren, konnte man das ausführen. Aber das Ausführen ist das eigentlich Schwierige, dass es ausgeführt wird.
Thanks for that.
Snowden, Surveillance.
Ja, das Problem ist, also zu der ganzen Snowden-Geschichte, ich weiß nicht, wie man das machen kann, aber es ist einfach.
Das Problem ist, also zu der ganzen Snowden-Geschichte, ich glaube, er hat nicht damit gerechnet, wie bescheuert und scheißegal das den meisten Leuten ist.
What? Was zum Teufel ist das?
Hacking Competition mit Publikum und Saufen dabei. What the fuck?
Also das, was er am Anfang gesagt hat, hat Sinn ergeben, ja? Irgendeinen Webserver mit SSL an und so. Aber was zum Teufel ist das hier?
Das Problem bei solchen Sachen ist, dass die meisten Leute, ich spreche jetzt mal nur für Leute, die ich kenne, aber ich weite das mal aus,
dass die meisten wirklich guten Leute und auch extrem computer- und technikinteressierten Leute, die sowas können, dass das nicht unbedingt die extrovertiertesten Party-Leute sind.
Ich meine, es hilft schon ungemein, wenn man unter sich ist, wenn die Leute eben sich kennen und wenn die Leute wissen, da sind keine Kacknoobs dabei, das hilft schon mal,
aber es mutiert keiner vom Hacker, der am liebsten seine Ruhe hat und am liebsten in Ruhe vor sich hin programmiert,
zum auf Partys rumschreienden, alkoholtrinkenden Computer-Hackzermann. Also das, ich glaube, ganz so extrem kann das nicht sein.
Nur das ergibt Sinn, was er erzählt hat.
Oh nein!
Alles klar!
Das ist ein direkter Match zu dem Signal in Katar.
Siehst du hier, Access entkodiert, Gigabyte RAM sollte den Trick machen. Wo ist er?
In diesem Clip versucht er, ein Gigabyte RAM zu verbreiten, aber das Gigabyte RAM ist wirklich nicht wichtig für das Verbrechen.
Du brauchst vielleicht eine besondere Erinnerung, aber das ist nicht etwas, das du in der Mitte deiner Operation tust.
Also nicht so realistisch.
Black Hat, NSA-Hacking.
Ist das Thor? Ist das Thor? Sieht irgendwie ein bisschen so aus.
Das ist gar nicht so unrealistisch, einen E-Mail-Anhang mit manipuliertem PDF.
Nein, ich meine nicht den Thor-Browser.
Ja, das ist er. Das ist er, oder?
Was ist ein Passwort? Wer soll das denn merken?
Wir wissen alle, dass das einzig wahre Passwort 123456 ist.
Das ist auch schwachsinnig.
What is happening? Warum beschießen sich da zwei Energiebälle?
The visualized 3D orbs in real space are not so accurate.
In the future machines will be able to think and will have access to physical components that they can actually move around.
Warum beschießen sich da Energiebälle?
This feels weird.
So we could see something like this, however the actual orbs of electricity or balls of electricity, that is pretty much set in science fiction.
We're out of my field here.
Criminal minds, hackers competing.
This might be the coolest girl I've ever met, but her gooey is mind blowing.
That's weird.
Warum haben die immer gerne so aufploppende Dinger?
Grill.
This is also kind of similar to hackers, where two hackers were competing, taking over control of a machine. It was a bit more accurate in hackers, as they were essentially competing on the same target system, trying to prevent the other person from accessing it.
In this, you see, they're competing on a system, but then someone else's system actually gets hacked.
What the hell?
In this case, there are multiple systems getting hacked.
It's just a little bit.
They mentioned the Linux operating system.
It's completely Linux based, open source programming.
You don't see this in government systems, I mean outside of Switzerland.
Which actually is used in plenty of governments.
Are you serious?
Lots of open source software is used sort of across...
Das ganze Internet wird ohne nicht funktionieren.
...the world, including our government.
Right, I get it.
The gooey comment is not too accurate.
Her gooey is mind blowing.
Usually when you're breaking into something, you're not actually going to run into any gooey or graphical user interface.
That's weird.
And even if you do, it's usually not that exciting.
Sneakers. Freaking.
I'm going to bounce this call through nine different relay stations throughout the world and off two satellites.
Good afternoon.
National Security Agency, Director of Operations, please.
Who is this, please?
It's my dime, I'll ask the questions.
It started the trace.
Guck mal, die können sogar nachverfolgen, wie weit sie sie zurückverfolgt haben.
Das halte ich mal für bescheuert.
...of freaking, where they're actually jumping not just to one other machine over the phone.
Who are you, Mr. Abbott?
I made the second leg.
But actually relaying from phone to phone to phone.
Can you guarantee my safety?
Where is the item?
Hang up, they've almost got us.
Hang up, Bish!
Freaking is not as popular anymore as most machines are Internet connected rather than dial up or phone connected.
We make the call, but we make it our way.
Algorithm.
Hacking via email.
You know where the weakest link in any security system is?
It's you.
With your shitty passwords.
And how you share every part of your life online.
And now I own Sam Novak's computer.
In this clip they're not showing too much of the...
Das passiert überhaupt nix.
...but he does mention that he's exploiting the kernel.
I'm just exploiting the vulnerability her kernel access...
Über Mail?
Rude exploit, kernel, über Mail.
Nicht schlecht.
This is pretty difficult to do.
However, there has been a recent vulnerability in antivirus software.
There's always a way in.
Where if you received an email with a very specific exploit,
it could actually exploit the antivirus software running in your kernel,
which is essentially your operating system,
and give the attacker full control of your computer.
Means they work for me.
I think that's what they're implying here,
even though they're not really showing the actual exploit.
Excellent.
Conclusion.
Hollywood has the challenge of depicting hacking,
which can actually be quite a challenge.
Okay.
War gar nicht schlecht, das Video.
Aber kann das sein, dass ich jetzt irgendwie
ne Stunde zu 25 Minuten Video gelabert hab?
Nee, kann nicht sein.
Ich hab den Rechner neu gestartet, zwischendurch.
Ganz so lang ist es nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, ganz so lang ist es nicht.
Okay, was gucken wir dann als nächstes?
Was gucken wir als nächstes?
Langweilig.
Battlefield.
Five worst...
Ich glaub, das Video sucked.
Das ist so ein Mainstream-Noob-Video.
Okay.
Komm, wir gucken uns mal mit.
Ich hab ewig kein Video von Dinos angeguckt.
Gucken, ob das was taugt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber...
Ich war noch nie großartiger Stammzuschauer
bei Dinos Tech Tips.
Ich hab immer mal wieder reingeguckt,
wenn voll interessante Videos waren.
Aber ich muss sagen, so in letzter Zeit,
ich guck mir vielleicht von 30 Videos eins an.
Wenn das übersteuert.
Ja, jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
What the fuck?
Also, ich mein...
Will er ein Schrott-PC zusammenbauen?
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Erst mal sehr laut überspringen.
Ist das ein Notebook?
So Dinger machen die in China übrigens gerne.
Du kannst ja bei AliExpress alte Intel Notebook-CPUs bauen.
Die haben sie aus Notebooks ausgebaut
und auf einen anderen Sockel gepackt,
sodass du sie jetzt im Desktop einbauen kannst.
Die Chinesen sind da gnadenlos.
Das Video ist langweilig.
Kein Bock.
Kein Bock zu gucken.
Ich glaub, da kommt nichts Gescheites bei rum.
Das Mutter...
Stimmt, das Mutterbrett.
Das ist nicht das Mämmer.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Geht nur neun Minuten.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal schnell an.
Also, wenn ich mal so überlegen müsste,
die schlimmsten Computer während der letzten Zeit.
Also, das, was mir am meisten im Kopf hängen geblieben ist
die letzten Jahre, war Loki eigentlich.
Sowas, was verbreitungsmäßig Schaden angerichtet hat.
Gucken wir mal.
Kannst du mich mal an Loki erinnern?
Okay, okay, okay.
Was sind das für Cuts?
Warum müssen die zu ihm hincutten und dann wieder zurück?
What the fuck?
Warum cutten die auf ihn hin und cutten von ihm zurück?
Das ist Aufmerksamkeit Spannendes normalen YouTube-Users.
Ja.
Ja, komm zum Punkt.
Auf, komm zum Punkt.
Das Schlimme ist, das klappt heute immer noch.
Aber, so verbreiten sich die meisten Viren nach wie vor.
Stimmt, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Ja, das war die Zeiten, wo Word noch standardmäßig
Makros ausgeführt hat.
Das war so fail.
Aber glücklicherweise bin ich relativ schnell
auf den Richter gekommen, dass Office-Programme
überflüssiger crap sind und hab schon ewig
kein Office mehr installiert.
Ja, so laflassend, als würde ich machen.
Klingt gut.
Ja, ich kann mich da noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Was ist denn ein gutes Antivirus-Programm?
Benutz den Windows Defender und fertig.
Da bist du ganz gut mit aufgehoben.
Der Windows Defender ist auch nicht besser
oder schlechter als der andere Kram.
Oder ist von Microsoft?
Und Microsoft traue ich noch am ehesten zu,
dass sie keinen Scheiß bauen,
was ihr eigenes Betriebssystem verkackt.
Aber Gehirn ist eh das beste Antivirus-Programm.
Ja, das stimmt.
Echt, die haben den gefangen?
Oder erwischt?
Oh ja.
Okay, das ist aber auch schon lange her.
Das ist auch schon lange her.
Und das habe ich damals schon nicht kapiert,
wie die Leute so bescheuert sein können
und darauf reinfallen.
Ja.
So.
Ah.
Falsches E-Mail.
Also, das habe ich damals schon nicht kapiert,
wie die Leute nach wie vor auf E-Mail-Anhänge reinfallen.
Das war vor 20 Jahren.
Und die Leute fallen immer noch drauf rein.
Alla Visual Basic.
Ja.
Versteckt das.
Das verstehe ich übrigens bis heute nicht.
Das ist bis heute die Fault in Windows,
dass Dateiendungen nicht angezeigt werden.
Guckt euch...
Ah nee, ich habe es eingeschaltet.
Ich habe es eingeschaltet.
Die Fault ist, dass Dateiendungen nicht angezeigt werden.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Ah ja.
Man könnte ja...
Supportik schreibt gerade damit,
der normale User nicht aus Versehen,
die da Zeilen zerstörpern.
Man könnte es ja so machen,
dass es angezeigt wird,
aber man es standardmäßig ohne extra Shortcut
oder so nicht umbenennen kann, die Endung.
Also, Möglichkeiten gibt es da ja genug.
Aber man sollte halt nichts verstecken vom User.
Das ist ja an vielen Stellen gefährlich,
wenn man Informationen vom User versteckt,
woran man Sachen erkennen könnte.
Kann ich mich schneller dran erinnern?
Okay, also die ordentlichen Seiten,
die da vor ordentlichen Datenbank laufen,
die waren nicht betroffen.
Microsoft SQL Server.
Gibt es jetzt auch für Linux Microsoft SQL Server?
Also, wenn Postgres, MySQL, MariaDB,
hast du nicht gesehen, alles nicht reicht,
Microsoft SQL unter Linux verwenden.
Wobei, ich stehe der Sache eher so gegenüber.
Kaputt.
Direkt umsteigen, ja, auf.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Das war eben ein Botnetz, ne?
Ja, das war eben eine Botnet-Geschichte.
Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Kappenpeng, also die Arduino IDE finde ich eh nicht gut.
Ich würde Platform.io verwenden.
Und vorher musst du gucken, ob das Device da ist halt.
Mach mal einen D-Mask auf und guck, also,
stöpsel an, deinen Controller stöpselt an, mach einen D-Mask und guck, ob das Device erkannt wird.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Ja.
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Was, das sollen die 5 Worst-Computer-Viruses gewesen sein?
Also, da haben andere deutlich, ach so, das ist von 2016, aber trotzdem,
da haben andere, gerade irgendwelche Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner-Geschichten,
die sich dann auch in Firmen verbreitet haben,
haben mit Sicherheit mehr Schaden angerichtet in den letzten Jahren als die.
Ah, ok, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
Da war fast nichts drin.
Ich glaub, das Video ist langweilig.
Der zeigt irgendwie nur einen Brief und dann knackt er das Ding in 20 Sekunden.
Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Das ist nicht so spannend.
Aber ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wie easy der Typ Schlösser knackt.
Das müsst ihr mal angucken, ja.
Das ist übelst krass.
So, zack.
Was auch immer das für ein Poggers-Tool ist.
Big Brain-Tool.
Guckst du Daily Dose auf Internet ab und zu mal, ja.
Es ist nicht meine Daily Dose.
Poggers-Schlösser knacken, easy, so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er macht, ehrlich gesagt,
aber es sieht high skill aus, ja.
Das musst du dir bestimmt über einen Tor-Browser im Darknet bestellen, das Tool.
Nein, wahrscheinlich kannst du das überall kaufen.
Wahrscheinlich sogar bei Amazon.
Es ist ja nicht verboten, solche Tools zu haben.
Ey, wo wir gerade dabei sind, das kann man sich nur im Darknet kaufen.
Letztens habe ich wieder gesehen, da haben so die Mainstream-Zeitungen
mal wieder aufgegriffen, dass man sich jetzt im 3D-Drucker Pistolen ausdrucken kann.
Da habe ich dann echt wieder vorgesessen, das ist so ein Thema,
das kommt dann wieder auf und dann schreiben alle Zeitungen drüber.
Oder alle Newsportale.
Wo ich mir dann auch gedacht habe, okay, du kannst aus dem 3D-Drucker
das Mögliche ausdrucken, aber du kannst keine funktionsfähige Pistole ausdrucken.
Du kannst dir ein Gehäuse ausdrucken oder sagen wir mal so ein Rohding,
wo du dann zu einer Pistole umbauen kannst.
Und das Schwierigste, was du brauchst, ist Munition.
Also du kannst ja nicht aus dem 3D-Drucker eine Pistole ausdrucken, die dann einfach schießt.
Du brauchst Munition, dass du damit schießen kannst.
Und außerdem einfach so, die Halterung an sich, ob das jetzt eine Halterung aus dem 3D-Drucker ist
oder ob da einer besonders begabt ist und sich irgendwie was aus Holz zusammenwurstet oder so,
macht doch keinen großartigen Unterschied.
Du brauchst Munition und du brauchst irgendwas, was das Ding zündet letztendlich.
Und wenn du das hast, dann kannst du wahrscheinlich auch mit einem normalen Gardinenhalterrohr was abfeuern.
Also ich weiß nicht, was da die Aufregung war, dass man sich quasi aus dem 3D-Drucker
Plastikpistolen ausdrucken kann. Wo ist das Problem?
Da konnte ich mal wieder nicht ganz nachvollziehen, über was man sich da gerade aufregt.
Zumal es relativ einfach ist, wenn man keine Vorstrafen hat und gerne schießen will, das zu machen.
Also wir haben, glaub, mindestens vier Leute auf der Arbeit, die hobbymäßig auf dem Schießplatz rumballern.
Und für die ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich glaube, das einzige, was du machen musst ist, du darfst keine Vorstrafen haben,
du musst das Ding registrieren, deine Waffen und du musst dafür sorgen, dass die ordnungsgemäß aufbewahrt werden.
So und ich glaube, das ist alles.
Ja, in der Schweiz, da weißt du eh nicht, was das Sache ist.
So, was haben wir denn hier noch sonst? Warum Lo-Fi-Music so beliebt ist?
Okay, warum? Warum?
Nicht persönlich, nee.
Dieses Mädchen, sie sitzt an ihrem Schreibtisch und macht Hausaufgaben, ihre Katze sitzt auf der Fensterbank. Jeden Tag schauen ihr 30.000 bis 40.000 Menschen dabei zu, aus aller Welt.
Na ja, eigentlich schauen sie ihr nicht zu, sondern hören hin.
Eventuell sagt euch das jetzt gar nichts, aber Lo-Fi-Musik ist...
Ich mag das nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich dabei weder besser konzentrieren, noch entspannen.
Wahnsinnig beliebt. Wer Lo-Fi-Hip-Hop auf YouTube sucht, stößt auf unzählige Videos.
Ich mag das auch nicht, ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Mit hunderten Millionen von Views. Sie alle zeigen Anime-Szenen der großen Klassiker und die Beats vermitteln ein schwer greifbares Gefühl der Nostalgie.
Von Producing-Legenden und Adult-Swim-Bumpern zu Merkel-Wave und einer riesigen dezentralen Bewegung.
Was ist Lo-Fi überhaupt? Woher kommt der Sound? Warum ist er so beliebt? Und kann er dir vielleicht helfen, produktiver zu werden?
Ich höre mir irgendwelche Chill-Compilations gedönnt an, aber Lo-Fi mag ich nicht.
Aber am besten ist eh eine Runde Heavy Metal in your face.
Gatschi-Bass.
Oh, Monkathos. War ganz davon abgesehen. Also ich hasse modern Pop und ich mag auch kein Lo-Fi.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen dem Crap und Lo-Fi, dann würde ich tatsächlich Lo-Fi sogar noch vorziehen.
Lo-Fi ist im Prinzip relativ...
Und man muss sagen, die kann echt nicht schlecht singen. Ich hab mal ein Video gesehen, da hat sie irgendwas ein bisschen Anspruchsvolleres gesungen.
Die kann echt gar nicht schlecht singen, aber diese Musik ist einfach Crap.
Wird es Battlefield 6 Streams geben, wenn es rauskommt? Bestimmt. Aber erstmal muss Battlefield 6 rauskommen und Battlefield 6 was taugen.
Aber was sind die Ursprünge der Lo-Fi-Musik von heute? Es begann in Detroit in den 90ern mit einem jungen Produzenten, James Duit Yancey, besser bekannt als Jay Diller. Der Rest der Welt baute zu dieser Zeit elektronisch perfekt getimte Beats mit der MPC. Dillers Methode wirkte dagegen recht unorthodox.
Anstatt die Drums perfekt auf die Beats zu legen, spielte er sie bewusst leicht versetzt. Das gab seiner Musik ein ganz anderes, menschlicheres Feeling.
Die Tracks des Produzenten Nujabes klingen ähnlich. Nujabes wurde am selben Tag wie Jay Diller geboren, nur auf der anderen Seite der Erde.
Seine jazzigen, täuschend simplen Samples beeinflussen bis heute die Melodien und Klänge von Lo-Fi. Beide Produzenten nutzten oft alte Schallplatten für ihre Samples, daher der charakteristische, zerkratzte Sound. Nujabes besaß sogar zwei eigene Platten.
Nujabes produzierte in den frühen 2000ern auch die Musik für den gefeierten Anime Samurai Champloo.
In den USA wurde Samurai Champloo auf dem dortigen Fernsehsender Adult Swim ausgestrahlt. Ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit integrierte der Sender Low Fidelity Sounds, Beats und Ansagen in sein Programm und die Marke. Bis heute ist Adult Swim eng mit Lo-Fi Musik verbunden und hat sogar eigene Playlists.
Für Millionen von jungen amerikanischen Zuschauern verschmolzen Anime und Low-Fi Hip-Hop unzertrennlich. Die Low-Fi Ästhetik ist voll von Klassikern wie Cowboy Bebop. Das Study Girl vom Anfang ist eine Abwandlung eines Charakters aus Whisper of the Heart, ein Studio-Ghibli-Film. Jay Diller starb 2006 viel zu früh an einer Krankheit. Nujabes kam vier Jahre später bei einem Autounfallungsleben.
Ok, 36 Leute, langsam wirds bei mir eng.
Doch wie wurde Low-Fi jetzt zu einem YouTube-Lernphänomen? Um 2015 herumtauchten immer mehr Kanäle auf YouTube auf, die 24-7 Live-Videos zu Low-Fi-Radio-Stationen umfunktionierten. Heute haben Chilled Cow oder College Music Millionen von Abonnenten. Das Genre ist explodiert.
Ich krieg das öfters mal empfohlen, aber ich hab nicht gedacht, dass das so ein Riesending ist.
Der Dienst to Relax Study 2 Radio ist dabei Kundgebungsort zahlloser, beispiellos eloquenter Diskussionen und Monologe aus aller Welt. Zum Beispiel I'm a Carrot. Es gibt kaum große Namen in der Szene, der Großteil der Low-Fi-Artists arbeitet ohne Label. Damit steht Low-Fi in totalem Kontrast zur milliardenschweren Popindustrie, in der Plattenfirmen Künstler groß machen oder klein halten können, in der Musik immer auch profitabel sein muss.
Low-Fi ist dezentralisiert und in seltensten Fällen wie Bitcoin. Jeder und jede kann mitmachen. Alles geht.
Zwischendurch einen Moment innehalten.
Moment, das ist Merkel Wave? Das gibt es wirklich, ja? Das gibt es wirklich? Ernsthaft jetzt?
Was?
Okay Leute, ich bin grad sprachlos. Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, dass es das wirklich gibt.
Das Internet!
Was?
Ach du große Scheiße! Okay, heute lernt man doch was, heute lernt man doch was.
Danke, Merkel. Es gibt Low-Fi Versionen von Jazz, Klassik und bekannten Hits. Die Tracks sind dabei häufig keine Musik, die man wirklich hört.
Auf seltsame Weise ist Low-Fi eher gemacht, um wegzuhören, etwas anderes zu tun. Das Mädchen zeigt, worum es geht.
Low-Fi ist die perfekte Begleitung an einem verregneten Lerntag und wirkt angenehm fokussierend. Denn Hintergrundmusik kann uns tatsächlich dabei helfen, uns zu konzentrieren.
Wissenschaftler der University of Tech.
Chad, wir sind alle big brain genug, da brauchen wir das nicht. Wir sind immer konzentriert.
Wir haben getestet, welchen Einfluss Musik auf die Arbeit von Chirurgen hat. Mit Musik waren die Ärzte im Operationssaal im Schnitt 8-10% schneller und ihre Resultate waren besser.
Okay, Geschwindigkeit im Operationssaal, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das so gut ist.
Also der soll sich zum Schnibbeln ruhig seine Zeit lassen, dass er auch richtig schnibbelt.
Was hebst du heute noch lange, weiß ich nicht. Gucken.
Excellent.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen, das leuchtet ein.
Also solange die nur 8-10% schneller werden und nicht anfangen Speedruns mit Timers zu machen, so nach dem Motto erstmal Lebertransplantation, Speedrun Timer mit ähm, wie heißt das, wenn sie Zwischensteps haben in dem Timer?
Mit so Milestones dazwischen, okay jetzt hier, das ist angeschlossen, das ist angeschlossen, Tap, next, Split, Split heißt es, genau. Nächster Split, okay jetzt kommt das.
Also keine Ohrwürmer.
Also die sollen, die sollen ruhig, die sollen in Ruhe, die sollen in Ruhe den Kram machen, ja.
Und auf gar keinen Fall Lyrics. Die Musik sollte ruhig und...
Wenn resettet wird, wenn resettet wird, ist auch ziemlich schlecht.
Also genau das, was Lo-Fi ist. So können diese Studien ein Indiz dafür sein, dass Playlists wie die vom Kanal Chilled Cow tatsächlich halten, was sie versprechen.
Da Kurse skippen.
Vielleicht können sie ja auch euch beim Lernen oder Studieren oder Arbeiten helfen.
Lo-Fi Sound entspringt den Köpfen zwei richtungsweisender Produzenten und ist unzertrennlich verbunden mit einer eigenartigen Anime- und Kindheitsnostalgie.
Es erinnert uns an Zeiten, die wir nicht selbst erlebt haben. Die Musik wird dezentralisiert, produziert und verbreitet.
So könnte sie nicht weiter entfernt sein von der glänzenden Makelosigkeit moderner Popmusik.
Für uns eine wahnsinnig schöne, angenehme Ecke YouTubes und des Internets.
Also meine Musikrichtung ist es nicht.
Exzellent.
Aber was haben wir gesehen? Wir können eine Runde Battlefield gucken.
Wir können eine Runde Battlefield gucken. Wir haben schon lange keine Runde Battlefield mehr geguckt.
Das haben wir schon mal geguckt. Das haben wir vor zwei Wochen oder so geguckt. Das Non-Euclidean-Dings.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch?
Das ist alles, glaube ich, nicht so spannend.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz interessant.
Wie der Windows-Papierkorb funktioniert.
Okay, Champ.
Das ist ganz gut, okay.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Oh, das ist ein Video mit nur Text. Okay, da muss ich jetzt was zu erzählen.
Wenn man ein Datei lasht, kommt es in den Papierkorb. Ja.
Es ist mehr als ein normaler Fold. Das stimmt. Man kann zum Beispiel die gleiche Datei mehrfach,
also die gleiche Datei mit dem gleichen Namen mehrfach in den Papierkorb werfen.
Das stimmt.
Was C? Recycle Bin.
Warum ist er in C? Warum ist er nicht in meinem Heimatverzeichnis?
Ich dachte, der Papierkorb ist für jeden User extra.
Für jeden User oder für jede Platte? Keine Ahnung.
Ah, für jeden User. Für jeden User ist da einer, okay.
Das scheint mir wieder eine übelst komplizierte Windows-Geschichte zu sein. Einfach so ein Papierkorb.
Fly.
Jetzt brauchen wir auch noch WSL, dass man Windows-Geschichte verwenden kann.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Files, dadurch dass die Files im Papierkorb gleiche Namen haben können,
werden die vorher umbenannt und irgendwo wird gespeichert, wie es ursprünglich hieß.
Ja, genau. Das dachte ich mir auch. Die werden umbenannt, dass es keinen Namenskonflikt gibt.
Und dann gibt es den Meta-Deicher-File, da steht drin, was es vorher hieß.
Boah, okay, ist alles nachvollziehbar jetzt, ja. Das ist nachvollziehbar.
Nee, da steht hier drin, wie es ursprünglich hieß.
Ja, das ist das Meta-Wetter-Filen. Hier steht, wo es ursprünglich gelegen hat.
Ich dachte, dass er da restaurieren kann. Klingt doch logisch.
Ja, gut, okay. Das ist dann doch nicht so spannend.
Dann gucken wir jetzt eine Runde Battlefield. Ich wollte die ganze, ich wollte schon immer wieder eine Weile.
Metro, No-Fly-Zone. Okay, was haben wir denn zu Auswahlen? Metro vom 12. August oder No-Fly-Zone?
Metro Only ist natürlich ein bisschen hardcore, ja.
Boah, das ist nice. Also, dass der mehrfach hintereinander die Piloten geschneibt hat, ist schon nicht in die Übel.
Das ist schon ganz schön pock.
Exzellent.
Was ist das? Noch ein kleines Kochvideo.
Das können wir gleich gucken.
Ja, mit diesen Dingern was zu treffen ist schwierig.
Nicht schlecht.
Also, der trifft mit dem Typen verdammt gut.
Guck mal, der rappt sogar sein eigenes Zeug.
Das ist ein richtig geiler Clip.
Ich meine, er killt erstmal mit dem LLV zwei Helis, dann killt er noch ziemlich genau mit der Kanone ein paar Leute und dann schießt er noch mit seinem RPG ein paar Helis ab.
Also, das ist schon nicht ohne.
Wusstest du gar nicht, dass du auf Twitch streamst? Ja, schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Schon eine ganze Weile. Aber ich heiße auf Twitch anders, weil das ursprünglich ein Channel war, mit dem ich selbst nur zugeguckt habe.
Ich wollte damals eigentlich gar keinen Channel erstellen und danach habe ich mir gedacht, okay, es ist gar nicht so schlecht, wenn ich anders heiße wie auf YouTube.
Weil es gibt auf YouTube teilweise schon ein paar Deppen, die bei mir am Channel am Start sind und alle, die ihren Weg hierher finden, das sind halt keine davon.
Deswegen habe ich mich auch noch nicht umbenannt. Ich werde mich wahrscheinlich auch nicht umbenennen.
Aber der Clip ist wirklich huge. Ich meine, guck mal, der hat mit dem LLV Helis gekillt, der hat mit der Kanone vom LLV und dann noch zwei Helis mit dem RPG abgeschossen.
Also, das ist ein Poggers Clip.
Der Keks hat zwar, ja zumindest habe ich das gleiche Profilbild. Außerdem sind hier nur Big Brain Leute, genau, exzellent.
Also mit dem Heli Jets zu killen ist schon gar nicht mal so ohne.
Was? Echt? Was? Ist das so?
What? What is happening?
Okay, okay, wenn man die TV Missile killt, stirbt der Gunner?
Was? Okay, just Battlefield things würde ich sagen. Das ist Battlefield Logik.
Also wenn man die TV Missile killt, die den Gunner abgeschossen hat, dann stirbt der Gunner?
Das ist Battlefield 4. What the fuck?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das möglich ist.
No way.
Oh, das waren ein paar Deutsche.
Nosehairkenners.
Zack, oh nice.
Okay, der Heli hat keinen Bock ordentlich zu fliegen, oder?
Der fliegt jetzt voll rein mit dem Schuss, bam.
Exzellent.
So Clips finde ich immer richtig geil, vor allem wenn sie danach wieder im eigenen Heli landen.
Richtiger Hanzo schon.
Simple Geometry.
Ja, die Jetpiloten müssen ja schon richtig mithelfen, dass das funktioniert.
Zumal auch kein Mensch da ist.
Das könnte durchaus gestellt sein, ja.
Der macht ja gar nichts. Der steht einfach.
Der hat das gestellt.
Oh, das ist natürlich nicht übel.
Der Heli muss reinfliegen, aber das ist cool, sowas zu treffen.
Progress.
Zack.
Wegen solchen Sachen sitzt teilweise das ganze eigene Team da und schneibt, weil sie alle sagen, ich will geile Schneiberkills machen und keiner spielt das Game normal.
Deswegen, deswegen, beste Server sind die, die einen Sniper Limit haben.
Kann ja auch großzügig sein, aber es sollte nicht das halbe gegnerische Team Sniper sein dürfen.
Das haben wir schon mal gesehen, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Oder der hat 20.000 Clips an dieser gleichen, guckt euch mal das Hintergrundbild an.
Huge Berg im Hintergrund, Vorgastberg, Alter.
Oh, nice, nice.
Was, Console Players, habe ich das richtig gehört?
Sekunde, Console Players, wo ist mein PC Master Race Emote?
Ich finde es nicht, wo ist es?
Kann es sein, dass ich keins habe?
Leute, ihr müsst merken, habe ich, habe ich einen PC Master Race Emote?
Wo ist es, wo ist es, ich hab den, da, da ist es.
Monarch S, nee nee, Monarch S noch da.
Ah, da ist es, da ist es.
Jetzt muss ich das nur noch, jetzt muss ich das nur noch hier, ah, da ist es.
Okay, excellent, excellent.
Ha, das war schon verreckt.
Also das zu treffen ist nur wirklich nicht ohne.
Ich brauche wahrscheinlich 50 Versuche, dass einer mal hittet.
Und zack, wieder rein in den Chat.
Oh, das war aber knapp.
What?
Okay, das war mega Glück.
Also da kann mir keiner erzählen, das war predicted.
Ich muss in der anderen Chat schon aktiv fast reinsteuern.
Oh, cool, cool.
What?
Das war Sniper Limit, hä?
Get schreckt.
Was ist das für, das ist wieder für eine Bitrate im Hintergrund.
Zack, Kopf.
Kopf.
Man sollte bei Headshots weniger kriegen und eine gescheite Capture Card.
Wobei, das ist nicht Konsole, doch, das ist Konsole.
Moment, er macht, er macht Werbung.
Er macht Werbung, das ist jetzt neu.
Okay, jetzt haben wir so viel Heli gestellt, jetzt muss man uns noch mal 5 Minuten Metro angucken.
Das, warum blört das so, ist das Xbox?
Nee, das Playstation 3.
Oh, brain, Alter.
Das Battlefield 3 jetzt, ne?
Oh, richtig, richtig professioneller Streamer-Man hier in Battlefield 3 mit Webcam und allem.
Rex, beste, beste Pistole, beste.
Also ich muss sagen, die Rex, also die gab es ja im Bad Company 2 schon, aber in Battlefield 3 fand ich die guten Bad Company 2 auch gut.
Battlefield 3, Rex und die M1911, auch Poggers.
Rex ist geile Waffe gewesen.
Das hat auch, das hat auch, das hat auch, du hast auch so richtig einen Wumms gemerkt dahinter.
Komm hier wieder, wechspray da.
Jetzt schreckt, easy as fuck.
Okay, der checkt mal wieder gar nichts.
Ist das Hardcore, weil er kein Hardhat und nichts?
Ist bestimmt Hardcore, he?
Hardcore, Hardcore, Rush, Metro.
Moment, was war denn das für eine Waffe?
Hab ich nie verwendet, diese, die Shotgun.
Musste gar nicht besehen, dass die überhaupt in dem Spiel existiert.
Aber generell, Battlefield 4 hatte so viele Sachen, vor allem mit den Addons drinne.
Das war echt, Milliarden Dinger.
Also, es waren so viele Sachen in Battlefield 4 mittlerweile drinne.
Oh, die werden, die werden Hardcore weggesprayt jetzt.
Oh, kriegen die auf den Sack?
Er wird geflammt, er wird garantiert geflammt danach.
Fucking Shotgun Noob.
Guck mal, über drei Kilometer.
Okay, jetzt ist er aber ganz schön PP-Guy.
Ja, und sehen ihn irgendwie nicht.
Ich bin ja ein Dauerfeuer-Spray-Noob, deswegen spiele ich immer M416.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen schnellere Killtime hat die an M490 gehabt,
aber ich finde es im Handling halt einfach viel angenehmer.
Hast du Glasfaser?
Also, wenn du meinen Internetanschluss meinst, dann nicht.
Bei mir lokal für 10 Gigabit Netzwerk habe ich das schon.
Also, ich bin lokal moderner als mein Provider.
Oh, die werden aber hart weggesprayt, ey.
Beziehungsweise eigentlich weggetappt.
Wer nicht gesprayt ist jetzt ja nicht.
Kriegen aber auf den Sack her.
Übrigens, eines der wichtigsten Perks, die man mitnehmen muss.
Anti-Suppression.
Und jetzt noch mit der Reck-Spam.
Jawoll.
Der macht den Cell-Out immer gut zwischendrin.
Den kannst du gar nicht erahnen.
Beste Waffe, meine absolute Lieblingswaffe.
Aber er hat das falsche Visier.
Das Cobra-Visier ist das beste hier.
416 Cobra-Visier.
Das ist typisch Battlefield 3.
Die haben es mir nicht geschenkt.
Battlefield 3 Rätsel, die einfach nicht funktionieren.
Oh, wie sie nicht checken.
Nice.
Bam.
Ja, sehr schön.
Richtig in your face, jawoll.
Zack.
Get rekt.
Wie man in Battlefield 3 und 4 über 40 km wiederbeleben konnte.
Am besten war in Bad Company 2, wo du durch die Wand wiederbeleben konntest.
Guck mal, Battlefield 4 ist so alt.
Und das sieht immer noch relativ brauchbar aus.
Und der Sound von Battlefield ist halt immer poggers.
Bisschen heller könnte er vielleicht machen.
Dann checken sie es nicht.
Ah, dann kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Die checken es wieder gar nicht.
Wo kam der denn her?
Ist er da gerade gespawnt?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Viel zu viele, viel zu viele.
Übrigens, der Happy Beacon, den hatten wir mal, ich hab ja mal in letzter Zeit ein bisschen
kurz Battlefield gestreamt wieder.
Ab und zu mal.
Den hatten wir auch im Game.
Das war der, der rumgeflamet hat wegen dem Panzer.
Die werden aber Hardcore weggesprayt.
Flup, flup, flup, flup, flup.
Das ist aber ein heftiger Killstreak, den er da am Start hat gerade.
Massive.
Immer wenn ich da oben hingucke, kommt da nie einer raus.
Komm um die Ecke, komm um die Ecke.
Und bei meinem Glück wäre jetzt von links einer gekommen und hätte mich gekillt.
Alter, die sind aber auch Blindfische, ey.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Okay, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Hä, ist Battlefield, nee, nee, nee, ist Battlefield 4.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, sieht erstmal aus wie Battlefield 1, aber kann es ja gar nicht
sein.
Oh.
Zack.
Boah, wie sie sich wegbomben.
Alter.
Oder erstmal den No Scope raus.
Das ist ein geiler Clip gewesen, das ist ein cooler Clip.
Das ist genau, so Battlefield Clips mag ich, die sind einfach kurz und knackig.
30 Sekunden, alles weg, weggesprengt, weggenaus kommt alles geiles Zeug drin.
Da sind aber auch so Clips, die kann ich mir keine 20 Stück in Folge angucken, weil so
spannend ist es auch nicht, wie einer C4 auf die Köpfe von den Leuten wirft.
Oh, die werden weggespreht, jawoll.
LMG legit.
Sag mal, das sind 5 Milliarden Gegner und keiner guckt in seine Richtung, was ist das denn wieder?
Der hat bestimmt Fehler RGB Rahmen, ja.
Nice, nice Video, hat mir gefallen.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt als nächstes zu bieten?
Wie haben wir denn jetzt so viele Videos?
Auf geht's.
Resident Evil 2 war ein Playstation 1 Spiel, ne?
Ursprünglich.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, unpopuläre Meinung.
Mir hat 5, auch wenn 5 mit den alten Resident Evil Spielen nicht mal groß zu hören, mir
hat 5 echt Bock gemacht, weil es eines der wenigen komplett auf Koop ausgelegten Spiele
war.
Das Problem ist, also das Problem bei Playstation Spiel auf M64 ist ja ganz klar, die eine hat
eine CD mit 600, was hat eine CD, 650 MB oder so und der N64 Cartridge hatte was?
8 MB?
Also da ist ja schon ein Unterschied.
So, huge animations.
Auch Sound war für den N64 ziemlich schwierig, weil bei Sony konntest du einfach normale
Stücke aufnehmen und von der CD abspielen, das ging beim N64 nicht.
Konntest du nicht einfach, überlegt euch mal, ein popliches 5 Minuten MP3 ist so groß
wie ein Drittel von dem Gesamtspeicher von der N64 Cartridge.
Ich weiß, ich glaube 8 MB oder so war das Maximale, was drauf gepasst hat, ich bin mir
immer so sicher.
Maximum N64, also N64, weiß ich gar nicht.
Oh, 64 MB, 64 MB.
Trotzdem, trotzdem ist das nicht viel, gerade im Vergleich zu einer CD mit 650, ne?
Und die ganzen Final Fantasy Cutscenes und Gedöns, die damals die Leute so in Staunen
versetzt haben, gingen ja nur, weil es auf einer CD war.
Jetzt doch ein bisschen laut.
Jetzt guck mal, wie pixelig das damals war.
Ja, und es gab noch ein drittes Szenario, oder?
Gab es nicht, aber ein drittes, drittes, drittes Hinten-Szenario gab es doch, glaube
ich, auch noch.
Ja, also wie die von der CD mit 650 MB auf eine Cartridge mit 65 MB gebracht haben, ist
nicht ohne.
Nein, nein, Leute.
Das sieht unscherfer aus und plasser.
Wie stehst du zu Alkohol?
Wie soll ich dazu stehen?
Wer sich besaufen will, soll sich besaufen, ne?
Also ich, das einzige Sachen, wo ich was trinke, ist vielleicht noch mal an Weihnachten als
Investor, aber dann auch nicht, dass ich gleich rumkotzen muss.
Hältst du dich in Grenzen?
Das schlimmste, also die schlimmste Sache, wo ich mich dran erinnern kann, war, wie das
so ist, weil ich noch ein bisschen jünger war, da haben wir uns, da habe ich mich mal auf
jeden im Geburtstag so krass besoffen.
Das war das erste, wahrscheinlich auch eines der ersten Mal, wo ich so richtig, so richtig
mich besoffen habe.
Da musste der Typ, der Vater von dem, wo wir da Geburtstag gefeiert haben, der musste die
Tür zum Klo aushängen, weil wir nicht in der Lage, weil wir so besoffen waren, und wenn
wir kotzen mussten, weil wir zu dumm waren, durch die Türe vom Klo zu kommen.
Also wir haben es nicht geschafft, die Türe zu öffnen vom Klo, so fett ich war an mir,
aber wir mussten halt kotzen.
Und da hat er die Klo-Tür ausgehängt.
Das weiß ich noch.
Aber ansonsten, irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, das ist es wirklich nicht wert, und seitdem
übertreibe ich es eigentlich nicht mehr.
Was ich persönlich faszinierend finde an den alten Konsolen, ist, wie viel die trotz
technischer Limitierungen rausgeholt haben.
Ich meine, es gab, man darf das nicht vergessen, es gab auf einem Super Nintendo, am Ende der
Super Nintendo Lebenszeit, gab es Spiele, die hatten ein Intro, also ein Intro mit Ingame-Grafik
mit einem gesungen Titelsong und sowas.
Also, das ist was, wofür die Plattform im Leben nicht gemacht war.
Ja, 15 Minuten auf CD ist überhaupt kein Problem, vor allem mit dieser Kackauflösung.
Heute ist der Sound von Titanfall 50 Gigabyte groß.
Das ist aber auch schon ganz schön pixellig jetzt.
Also quasi, quasi so eine Art MP3 für Videos.
Ja.
Stimmt.
Ja, ja.
Was ist das?
Da erkennt doch keine Sauers.
Also, die haben auf die Cartridge quasi eine zusätzliche Recheneinheit gepackt, auf die
Cartridge, die dafür sorgt, jetzt Video zu decompressen oder was.
Weil der N64 zu lahm war.
Ah.
Das ist ja Big Brain.
Ey, das ist ja mega Big Brain.
Die nehmen einfach das Video, machen das kleiner, dass es weniger Speicherplatz braucht und
dann packen sie einen Upscaling-Chip auf die Cartridge, die das Video wieder hochskaliert.
Dass der N64 das nicht selbst machen muss.
Ok, natürlich verliert man ein bisschen Qualität dadurch, aber immerhin sieht es besser aus
als der andere Pixell-Crap.
Das ist Big, Biggest Brain.
Ha.
Ok, ok, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Also, die haben das Original-Video genommen, haben es kleiner gemacht, die Auflösung,
komprimiert und die Hälfte der Frames rausgelassen.
Und dann haben sie auf die Cartridge einen extra Prozessor gepackt, der das Ganze entkomprimiert
hat, Zwischenbilder berechnet hat und upscaled hat.
Sodass es in die N64-Cartridge gepasst hat und der N64 nicht überfordert war.
Exzellent.
Das ist Big Brain, Alter.
Das ist wirklich, das ist echt.
Also, ich mein, die mussten ja irgendwas machen, die hätten ja die Cutscenes sonst nie reingekriegt.
Aber wieso können sie den Speicher von der Cartridge nicht größer machen?
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil der N64 nur maximal so und so viel ansprechen kann
an Cartridge-Speicher.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Und, und, und, ich vermute mal, weil der Speicher auch relativ teuer war.
Genau, Red in a Box, das glaube ich auch.
Ich glaube, der Cartridge-Speicher war auch noch relativ teuer, weil ansonsten hätte
man da vielleicht irgendwelches Ummapping machen können mit extra, mit extra Storage,
mit irgendwie der extra Storage-Recheneinheit auf der Cartridge und noch im extra Storage-Modul.
Irgendwas hätte man vielleicht machen können.
Aber wahrscheinlich war auch der Speicher nicht gerade billig.
Aber guck mal, der Hintergrund sieht viel pixeliger aus dann.
Also es sieht viel plasser aus und die, der Sprache fehlt auch ein bisschen Dynamik,
ne?
Der hört sich fast ein bisschen an wie der G-Man in der N64-Variante.
Das hätte heute schon mal nicht funktioniert, weil heute hätte der kreative Musikmensch
gesagt, ich verwende keinen Windows, ich verwende nur Mac und dann hätte es schon mal nicht
funktioniert.
Ich prokramiere das lieber vor meinem iPad.
Okay, ich höre wirklich keinen Unterschied.
Das hört sich für mich wirklich exakt gleich an.
Aber die haben da echt richtig krass getrickst, muss man echt mal sagen.
Und ich finde das, ich finde das, ich finde das echt spannend, was sie teilweise mit
den alten Konsolen anstellen mussten, dass, dass sie überhaupt die Sachen umsetzen konnten,
die sie vorher hatten.
Wenn man sich überlegt, mal ein anderes Beispiel, wenn man sich überlegt, das erste Rollercoaster-Tycoon,
das hat der Typ komplett in Assembler gewurstet.
Also, da musst du, da musst du schon über einen ziemlich großen Kopf verfügen, dass
du das hinkriegst.
Du hast 80 Minuten Verspätung in der Bahn, ach du Scheiße, MonkaDB.
Okay, was?
von Nintendo selbst.
Ihr seht, sehr wenige Firmen
bekommen custom Mikrokode
ausgestattet,
selbst wenn sie ein Entwicklungsgerät haben.
Nintendo war immer sehr
secretive über ihre Mikrokode.
Aber Angel Studios und
Nintendo's Blessing konnten nur das machen.
Und sie haben auch den grünen Licht,
um mit Faktor 5 zusammenzuarbeiten,
auf Musi X.
Im Endeffekt ist Resident Evil 2
auf der Nintendo 64 eine tolle Port,
die zeigt, was erreicht werden kann,
mit der richtigen Optimisierung
und Entwicklung.
Wenn du dir überlegst, dass das
neun Leute
geportiert haben. Neun Leute!
Neun Leute!
So viel ist heute
die BWL-Abteilung groß,
die, äh,
oder irgendwelche Marketing-Leute.
Mit neun Leuten kommst du heute nicht weit.
Aber heute ist halt auch die ganze Ecke mehr drum herum.
Aber neun Leute ist echt eine Ione.
Da hat sich noch keiner für Burnout interessiert.
Die Leute wurden einfach geschaffen lassen
bis zum Umfallen.
Es ist genauso, wie der eine Typ erzählt hat,
ich weiß nicht mehr welcher der Leute von Doom war,
dass er seinen Arbeitsplatz irgendwann
aufs Klo verlegt hat, weil es ihn
immer als Programmieren unterbrechen musste,
wenn er kacken gehen musste.
Das sind mal First World Problems, oder?
Wenn dich aufregt, dass du
nicht weiter arbeiten kannst, weil du mal
scheißen musst.
Wieso machst du immer die Eins weg?
Das ist so ne Angewohnheit von mir.
Frank, spielst du noch Flight Simulator?
Ne, hab ich auch noch nicht.
Ich wollt mir den neuen mal angucken, ja.
Das alles.
So Leute, ich muss jetzt unbedingt was essen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend noch mal.
Ich muss das mit der Kamera ausprobieren.
Ich hab nämlich auch ne China Cam, die geflasht werden möchte.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns, bis später, machts gut.
See you.